e e
okay good morning everyone and welcome
to the science technology and energy
committee for Tuesday the 21st of
January
2025 we have a hectic schedule today
several public hearings and an executive
session at
3:30 before we begin we will commence
our meeting as we do by tradition by
asking everyone to rise and join retired
Navy Commander JD bernardy as he leads
us in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all okay so the plan this morning is to
have a public hearing on hb36 we'll
start that in just a minute hb36
establishes a commission to study the
short and long-term impacts of pending
National and Regional carbon pricing
mean mechanisms on New Hampshire
citizens businesses institutions and
environment at the conclusion of that
public hearing we will take a lunch
break we will return at one o00 to hear
HB
95- FN requiring the New Hampshire
Electric
Co-op to regularly file a certificate of
deregulation with the p Public Utilities
Commission then we'll hear House Bill
166 establishing a committee to
interview to review internet service
service providers infrastructure
transition plan from copper to
fiber and then we'll hear HB 526 FN
establishing a climate change and damage
division in the Department of
Environmental
Services and finally we'll hear HB 169
FN relative to a quorum of the Public
Utilities
Commission so we'll begin today with
House Bill 306 I'll formally declare the
public hearing for House Bill 306 to be
open and call on the prime sponsor of
House Bill 306 Wendy Thomas to introduce
the bill to us good morning
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you members of the community uh
for the record I am Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac I'm here
today to introduce uh House Bill
306 which is an act establishing a
commission to study the short and
long-term impacts of pending National
and Regional carbon pricing mechanisms
on New Hampshire's citizens businesses
institutions and
environment carbon pricing is a
market-based strategy to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by assigning a
monetary cost to emitting carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gases it
incentivizes businesses and individuals
to lower their emissions by making it
more expensive to pollute the goal is to
encourage cleaner energy use innovation
and efficiency while addressing climate
change other countries are already using
carbon pricing in order to lower costs
while the impacts of climate disruption
increase this economic lever insulates
consumers while putting the cost where
it belongs without a price signal
consumers remain at the mercy of a pro
of a market that is unfair because their
product doesn't include those
externalized costs passing this bill
would be beneficial to New Hampshire's
economy for several
reasons house bills 60 uh 306 sorry
ensures New Hampshire prepares for the
economic changes that could arise from
Regional or national carbon mechanisms
by studying these impacts the state can
avoid being caught off guard and
Implement strategies to mitigate
potential negative effects while
capitalizing on
opportunities understanding how carbon
pricing affects businesses allows the
state to create policies that protect
local industries from disproportionate
costs the study could help shape
measures to keep New Hampshire
businesses competitive especially in
Industries vulnerable to International
competition carbon pricing mechanis
mechanisms often reduce greenhouse gas
emissions which can improve air quality
healthier populations typically result
in lower healthare costs and increase
productivity positively impacting the
State state's
economy the study would evaluate how
carbon pricing might influ influence
state energy costs in the short and long
term this information is crucial for
planning strategies to ensure energy
remains affordable for residents and
businesses New Hampshire relies on
sectors like agriculture tourism and
Manufacturing this bill's Focus on
studying how carbon pricing affects
those Industries allows the state to
identify challenges and Implement
targeted solutions to protect jobs and
economic
activity by examining the car the
effects of carbon pricing and
positioning itself as prepared New
Hampshire could attract investments in
renewable energy Energy Efficiency and
other clean Technologies these
Investments often generate new jobs and
stimulate local economies
carbon pricing is becoming common common
globally and in the US studying its
impacts positions New Hampshire to
remain competitive in a transitioning
economy especially with trading partners
and neighboring states already moving
toward carbon pricing
mechanisms the study commission ensures
that any decision about implementing
carbon pricing is based on thorough
research and consideration of its
effects on public health the economy and
the environment
this prevents rushed or poorly designed
policies that could harm the economy the
study also examines how collected fees
might be returned to the residents
businesses and
municipalities ensuring any carbon
pricing program supports economic
resilience and mitigates potential cost
burdens by understanding the long-term
impacts the state can identify ways to
transition away from fossil fuels reduce
dependence on vol energy markets and
create a more sustainable and resilient
economy this bill acknowledges that the
outside world economies are already
using carbon pricing and we owe it to
New Hampshire's energy consumers to
understand how the global market excuse
me the global market signals will impact
energy rates here by passing this bill
we ensure that New Hampshire remains
economically competitive environmentally
responsible and strategically prepared
for the future thank you and I'll take
any questions thank you representative
for introducing House Bill
306 I have a couple of quick questions
for you is this the same bill that the
house defeated last year I believe it is
okay and the second question is the
state of New Hampshire or the
legislature already has about 200
Commissions in existence do you know if
there are any other commissions that
could take on this work uh without us
having to establish a new commission I
do not believe there is another
commission that could do that and I
understand we have a lot of commissions
but the importance of this to New
Hampshire's economy to uh its Industries
and to the health of its citizens I
think makes it a priority okay thank you
other questions for the representative
representative
Harrington yeah just one question uh you
talk about national uh carbon tax given
the events of yesterday do you really
think there's any chance we're going to
see a national carbon tax within the
next four
years when you say given yesterday do
you mean uh the the change of
administration you yeah Donald Trump
being president what he said I do you
think that there's a chance that they're
going to P he's going to sign a carbon
tax in the law in the next four years no
I don't however I think that the other
countries are going to to be uh actively
pursuing carbon fees and carbon uh uh
pricing and it's uh it's important for
New Hampshire to see what the
implications of that to our specific
economy
is other questions representative Kaplan
has one I got two questions uh for
representative uh Wendy Thomas I'm gonna
uh ask you does this first of all is
does this commission intending to
recommend that New Hampshire establish a
carbon pricing mechanism and second ly
could you I'm just going to return your
favor in the question you asked me in my
public hearing could you more
specifically tell us how this would best
position New Hampshire businesses uh for
the future sure this commission is not
to uh recommend a carbon pricing at all
for for the State of New Hampshire it's
to look at the implications of carbon
pricing if we don't do it which is not
recommending that we do or if it's not
done on a national level um with regard
to the impact of of the
economy
uh we're in a situation where we're
we're we're tied to fossil fuels and
fossil fuels are becoming um more
disruptive to our environment and to our
health and so by putting um a a price on
fossil fuels it the money will will will
help the industries
there is a gentleman that's going to
come behind me um who will better be
able to address
that additional
questions seeing none I want to thank
you representative for introducing this
legislation and I'll call next on
representative cat McGee and while she
makes her way to the test to the table
to
testify I will
uh let you all know that we have eight
people who want to testif on this bill
so from this point forward the timer
will be turned on and you'll each have
no more than 5
minutes representative McGee good
morning good morning thank you Mr
chairman and thank you me colleagues um
sorry for my voice I have a
cold okay um I'm representative cat
McGee Hillsboro 35 Hollis and I come to
you today not as a co-sponsor of this
bill but in support of the idea of a
study to learn learn more about the
impacts of carbon pricing on granite
sters uh the concept of carbon pricing
has been circulating around this
committee for as long as I've been on it
the number of countries using carbon
pricing was 46 when I first joined St in
2019 according to the World Bank report
in July of 2024 there are currently 75
carbon pricing instruments being
operated around the world Canada Mexico
and Panama are all using uh cap and
trade it's basically a cap and trade
program as an effective lowcost tool to
lower emissions while driving economic
growth uh the concept is to remove the
externalized costs of pollution from the
rate payer and place it on those that
are doing the polluting we have the
regional greenhouse gas initiative as an
example which is a large emitter cap and
trade program here in New England that
brings in an excess of $50 million uh
back to New Hampshire each
year uh Reggie was designed to give
States money to invest in emissions
lowering projects and we elected to use
over 95% of the regional greenhouse gas
initiative funds uh as rebates uh to uh
those rate payers so in effect we turned
Reggie into a pass through program from
polluters to rate payers carbon pricing
is designed to pass the credits
collected from polluters Back to the
bill payers so it is not a net tax to
Consumers it is a stimulus to economies
where it is being used and that is why
it's been so popular as far as Global
adoption um but do we know what will
happen if the US stays outside of these
Global uh energy market price signals do
we know how New Hampshire's preparation
for these changing markets will help or
or hurt New Hampshire consumers I don't
think we do that is the reason for the
study since the us is the only country
in North America not pricing carbon can
we count on any economic impacts to the
cost of our energy uh costs here in the
state in 2025 New Hampshire has no plan
to inform ourselves on the benefits
costs or impacts to our constituents
energy
bills hb36 asks the house committee on
science technology and energy to look at
the impacts of this global economic
policy on the state's ability to keep
energy costs low if we don't investigate
it we have no Knowledge from which to
propose a way forward for New
Hampshire hb36 is a study bill in the
first year of the bium that asks us to
shine more light on the idea that a
wider spread cap and trade program might
actually bring meaningful cost relief to
energy
consumers Would we not undertake any
policy that would do this all we need to
do is take a look and that is what I'm
asking for your consideration in passing
hb36 so that we have more information
with which to move forward as to what is
best for helping keep costs low and to
lower costs in the future for energy
consumers
thanks thank you representative McGee
I'm sorry to hear you have a cold yeah
hope you feel better soon thank you any
questions for representative McGee
uh representative Swanson
has thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
MC the
uh climate impacts or whatever are uh
often mentioned in regard to this and
certainly if indeed the burning of
fossil fuels are affecting climate in an
adverse
manner perhaps that would be a good
basis for promoting this but I'm
wondering the state uh passed a tax cut
a couple years ago and now I understand
that there are uh I'm sure that the ways
and means and finance are working on how
to
finance uh the state budget going
forward uh if there is uh and this
commission is just to do an assessment
if there were a a cap or a carbon tax is
there any estimate or would there be a
uh path forward to getting an estimate
of how much revenue it might bring to
the state if we could tax something that
ultimately uh we may you know uh there's
we don't want to invest in for the
future because uh we're having trouble
finding invest investors for the
long-term future
yeah it's a good question I think um
we've had we've had bills that that were
asking us to enact a cap and trade
program uh you know a carbon pricing
program that's not what this bill is
about though this Bill is saying we
should study what the impacts of the
existing market for those people who are
currently enacting uh these programs
we're in North America and no one else
in no other country in North America is
currently not doing this and so what we
want to look at is what are the
implications for us and our energy
Market based on the fact that we're
outside of those price signals and so
what does it make sense for us to do
does it make sense for us to pursue it
or are we better off not pursuing it we
don't have those answers that's what the
bill is trying to solve is to say what
is the best way forward because if we
claim that we're trying to help keep
people's costs low then we have to be at
least aware of the things that are
happening around us and how they will
affect those costs going forward so we
want to have a study rather than put it
off um so we have more information to go
forward
with representative schneller has a
question thank you Mr chairman and I
thank the representative for a testimony
um I'm wondering that the given much
uh sort of well given that the
underlying science is far from settled
um is it not premature to even consider
a commission to set up a scheme to trade
something that may or may not have an
impact um wouldn't isn't this just
extremely premature uh again the
committee isn't to study setting it up
the committee is to find out since 75
countries including all the other
countries in North America already
setting prices on their energy and us
not doing that we don't know what impact
that has on ratee payers in the in the
state so it's it's not trying to presume
any outcomes and it's not talking about
the science it's talking about the
economic policy in the energy sector
that says that folks are starting to
build in the externalized costs of
pollution to fossil fuel use and we are
not so what will that do to costs for
rate payers is it is it good for us is
it not good for us so that's it's really
more of an economic examination of the
reality of what's going on around us we
don't have to agree on climate change to
agree that 75 countries are pricing
carbon does that answer your question I
don't because I think the question was
kind of taking us off base because I
we're not we're not discussing whether
um the science is settled that's think
the question was simply that I is it is
it not premature to set up a commission
to study something that may or may not
be taking place um why not set up a a
nitrogen study commission um a helium
study commission carbon pricing is
taking place so again we're we're
talking past each other I think carbon
pricing 75 countries including Canada
and Mexico our nearest trading partners
and the rest of North America they are
all pricing carbon we are not pricing
carbon what is the impact of that on the
rates that people in New Hampshire will
have to pay okay that's what we want to
look
at okay I'd remind members that we're
here to ask questions to elicit
information we don't want to have any
debates at this point in time
representative Kaplan oh you have a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you uh representative McGee for for for
for testifying on this bill I'm
genuinely curious because I know that
you're you're somebody who thinks a lot
about energy issues and to follow up on
representative Harrington's question U
given the fact that we are the only
country in North America that doesn't
have a carbon pricing mechanism and
given the fact that the European Union
our largest trading partner besides
Canada also has a carbon pricing
mechanism and given the events of
yesterday do you think that this uh
commission would have more or less
importance given yesterday's new
Administration thank you for the
question um I think rather than this
bill being premature I think it's
timely um I think with what is going on
currently in the energy economy globally
we owe it to our constituents to
understand what it means for rate payers
here in New Hampshire um it it's not
talking about adopting it it's talking
about even if we don't adopt it we still
may have impacts for not participating
we should understand those um and they
can help inform Us in terms of policies
for the second year of the
bium okay seeing no further questions
for the representative
I'll call on next Mr Michael sonunu from
newfields representing
himself good morning and
welcome don't forget to turn on the
mic better there uh thank you very much
for giving me giving me the opportunity
to uh testify today on hp36 I'm here
representing myself um uh I have
attached a copy of a presentation I made
to the New Hampshire Bia years ago on
the carbon tax and an important issues
that taken as a whole should steer this
committee away from approving hp36 uh I
updated the figures in that presentation
on page 14 to indicate the most recent
year of energy consumption in the state
and how an example of a $40 uh per per
ton carbon tax would cost consumers as
noted in that material though the
potential for raising taxes on pretty
much every family and business in the
state to the tune of at least a half a
billion dollars a year at that level
there's a poor track record of
legislators keeping to the commitments
of how these funds would be used the
state as well as as well as many other
states regularly try to raid uh clean
energy funds and and grab that money in
addition the inevitable ratcheting up of
taxes happens we see it going on in
places that have enacted C carbon taxes
uh like Canada that was just mentioned
uh more importantly the results of these
types of taxes always fall on families
and businesses no matter what good
intentions are put in place by
legislators there there's often flowly
language that insists that companies
should not be allowed to pass these
costs on to Consumers but statements
like that in my opinion are a tcid
acknowledgement that they're going to be
passed on to comp on to Consumers that's
how the world Works beyond the issues
raised in that material I suggest the
members of this committee look at the
economics of imposing a carbon tax with
the best example right across the border
in Canada Canada as a whole passed a
carbon tax in
2019 uh and while they started the tax
at $20 per metric t for CO2 it's already
risen to $80 per ton in five short years
that's quadrupling the price while the
Canadian government implemented rebates
in order to sell the idea of a
broad-based carbon tax the economic
reality is is that families are paying
hundreds of dollars a year in higher
taxes because of the policy a recent
review of the numbers published by the
Parliamentary budget office in Canada
that was done by the Canadian taxpayers
Federation found that the carbon tax
will cost the average household in
Canada between $42 and $847 in 2023 even
after the
rebates looking at the projections from
the from the PBO it's only going to get
worse for families in Canada over the
next 5 to 10 years as a result there's
been major political backlash against
the liberal government driven by
taxpayer Revolt over the carbon tax it's
reached the point where the Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau had to resign
the liberal po party has been torn apart
and they'll likely face massive losses
in the upcoming elections this is a
lesson of the economic and political
realities of carbon tax in fact New York
State Governor hokel just announced that
she is going to delay the state from
considering her cap and invest program
and just uh this past week the largest
party in the European Parliament
announced that they are going to uh put
their carbon import tax on hold these
are the political realities it is not
that everybody's rushing to enact carbon
taxes they're actually moving away from
it on a global
basis lastly let me address a question
that comes up with legislation like hb36
which just establishes commissions right
there are dozens of organizations in the
state in the region or nationally that
Advocate on a regular basis for a carbon
tax many of these organizations receive
millions of dollars every year as just
one example 350.org which is a huge
advocate for eliminating fossil fuels
and imposing policies like a carbon tax
for their 20222 tax year reported $20
million in revenues in that year and has
almost $15 million of assets on his
books why can't organizations that are
in favor of this type of activity form
their own commissions invite elected
officials to serve on the commission ask
experts to testify before their
commission and have their commission put
out recommendations in my opinion it is
because they want the impr premature of
a state government on its actions and
recommendations these commissions are
almost always populated with individuals
who are already active in the policy
area that they're created to study
rarely did they cover new ground or
provide insightful analysis they
typically rehash existing materials and
put out pages and pages and pages of
recommendations but since their state
endorsed commissions it's inevitable
that some of these recommendations find
their way into influencing regulatory
policymaking regardless of whether the
legislature moves forward or not a great
example of this is the New Hampshire
Coastal risks and Hazard commission this
was established by SB 163 uh I think 11
years ago and it specifically stated
that the commission shall annually
report its findings and any
recommendations prop proposed
legislation to the speaker of the
Speaker of the House the president of
the Senate the house clerk the Senate
clerk the governor and the State Library
the idea of this commission at least as
I recall in in the debate around it was
to provide guidance to the general court
and the governor for what should be done
if anything about about uh if if
anything about coastal flooding but as
could have been predicted back then the
pages and pages and pages of
recommendations by the commission rarely
were adopted as legislation but much of
it is being adopted but unseen by the
general public and I would guess unseen
by many members of this committee rules
and policies are being made within Dees
do Regional planning authorities and
other organizations which get around the
difficulty of enacting legislation by
just quietly injecting restrictions on
development imposing unjustified new
building codes adopting honorous
infrastructure requirements and people
wonder why there's a housing crisis in
this state based on these reasons I urge
you all to reject a
hb36 thank you all and I'll take any
questions excuse me so uh representative
Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I'm just curious
uh carbon pricing has been around for a
long time and with so many countries
using
it do your does your research show that
the um overall temperature of the world
has come down or or that the emissions
have decreased significantly by these
you know uh countries you know using
that method so I I don't think this
legislation certainly doesn't uh I think
address the you know that particular
issue and I I don't I don't want to take
the committee's time up to debate that
um but let me just say that you know we
do have a a carbon a form of carbon tax
in the state and that's Reggie right
Reggie is a a form of regulation on
carbon emissions from uh power
generators and it's imposed across the
state and in the region as a whole um I
will say this the Northeast where Reggie
exists and places like California that
has something similar to Reggie in terms
of carbon trading they have the highest
energy cost in the country the states
that have imposed this have high energy
costs so I think that should be a
serious concern when you're looking at
uh even considering or debating the idea
of a carbon tax
uh one additional question before I let
you go I understand that you serve as a
selectman in your town of newfields
that's correct I've been there nine
years do you think uh studying a carbon
tax would be important for the members
of your
community well um uh let me let me say
this so you know a carbon tax at the end
of the day is is is really tax on energy
and from the perspective of somebody on
the local level at a select board I
served as a welfare officer in in
newfields for years um and the the
concern uh the issue that we had to most
often deal with as a welfare officer is
energy costs for uh low-income families
who live there and in the winter facing
huge electricity bills uh heating oil
problems um and so this certainly I
think a carbon tax would exacerbate that
um and and let me just say in addition
as a small community we're constantly
looking for development of our
commercial manufacturers we have a large
manufacturer in town um they they you
know they provide a lot of taxes and
that helps alleviate property taxes for
the families in town um higher energy
costs are what Drive businesses
Industries out of the state we've seen
it happen numerous on numerous occasions
right sixh hour expanded in Arkansas
because the energy prices up here are
too high uh I think it would be
crippling for my town to lose Hutchin
and ceiling system
because energy costs get too high and a
carbon tax is going to make energy costs
more expensive for businesses like that
and at the end of the day they'll leave
and the other families in town are going
to have to pick up the the the benefit
of of the property taxes that they
pay thank you additional questions
representative Bernardi has
one thank you Mr chair Mr sen you you
started off mentioning you updated a
document page 14
I'm I'm sorry I I forwarded this to to
the chairman with my testimony this was
a presentation I did to the New
Hampshire Bia uh about seven or eight
years ago that contains a lot of data on
on carbon taxes um I sent it in PDF
format I I apologize I I didn't realize
that that you as as members didn't get
it the the the the key aspect of that
just you know to if if you're going to
if if it gets circulated and look around
is on page 14 you know I I basically
identify the the usage of uh fossil
fuels here in the state and a a $40 per
ton carbon tax which is you know around
the typically what is typically
discussed you're talking about um
costing in just in New Hampshire not
regionally but just in New Hampshire
$500 million of additional taxes that
would come from a carbon tax now it
could be determined to to deal with that
in a variety of ways they could spend it
on new programs they could you know do a
rebate program like they did in Canada
but you you know that's the key takeaway
from this document and and I I assume
that the the chairman will be able to
circulate that thank you I will do that
and I apologize to the members of the
committee for not circulating it last
night uh I think I got distracted by the
Notre Dame Ohio
State any additional questions from
representative Kaplan has one thank you
Mr chair and thank you for coming in Mr
senuna uh from your testimony it sounds
like not only are you opposed to this
bill but you're opposed to any kind of
state commission any kind of uh task
force any kind of uh government uh
attempt at all to deal with uh the
problems of the externalities of the
energy system that we're currently uh
under and so my question to you is is is
a you know sort of a conceptual question
would you not agree that uh the the
public bearing the cost of those
externalities constitutes a subsidy for
the fossil fuel companies that would far
outweigh the $20 million that you
mentioned that a lobbying group such as
350.org uh enjoys uh to carry out its
operations so your question opens up a
broader area that uh I'd be happy to go
down but I don't think the committee
probably wants spent time on that and
that is the evaluation of the
externalities versus the benefits that
fossil fuels provide for everyday life I
I can say for certain that we couldn't
hold this hearing today nobody could get
here today this room would not be heated
this building wouldn't have been built
without fossil fuels and the evaluation
of the external externality cost to CO2
um there are Reams and reams of
scientific evidence that say that the
the benefits far outweigh the the cost
the perceived costs of that um like I
said if we want to have a broader
discussion on that I would be happy to
have it um to the other part of your
question with respect to commissions yes
I I'm skeptical of of of most
commissions because you know as somebody
who has been involved in government for
Going on 30 years I I find most
commissions to not really be worth the
time and effort they're mostly headline
Grabbers the and and the product for
most of them is is not something that
can be acted on now there are exceptions
to that rule uh but again I think my
testimony indicates I I am very
skeptical of the idea of a commission um
considering the the carbon tax doing
anything but promoting a carbon
tax okay thank you seeing no further
questions I want to thank you for whoops
there is one sorry representative
Swanson remember representative we're
here to elicit questions to obtain
information uh thank you Mr chair uh uh
and thank you Mr sonunu for being here
uh just uh uh to follow up a little bit
uh you're concerned about the cost to
New Hampshire of uh potential taxes I
believe
and of course you indicated opposition
to a commission to make a study but just
uh sort of honest uh from the standpoint
of
dependence on external energy sources
and you said energy but I assume you
referring to carbon-based energy as far
as your cost factors if uh we do not do
something will uh as far as discouraging
or perhaps addressing the amount of
carbon-based fuels that the state
consumes uh will does that just further
uh the state of New Hampshire's
dependence on external sources because I
don't think that we produce any fossil
fuels internally from New Hampshire
except perhaps well I mean wood is not a
fossil fuel but it's a carbon based fuel
but uh would it further our dependence
you don't have to answer that question
because it's not relevant to the in
front of us uh but but if you have a
quick answer I have a real quick answer
which is this is this is a broader
question about
macroeconomics and and and I I would
argue that the the economic literature
over the last several hundred years
shows that um you know uh and I go I'll
go to Adam Smith that that references
the fact that economies grow and prosper
and create value when they are you they
are utilizing resources that they can't
obtain externally but can provide
provide value externally and by
obtaining cheap reliable resources of
energy in this state we can generate
value we can create opportunities we can
improve the lives of families and
businesses here um and economics says
that that is actually a good tradeoff
for those economies that that do look at
the free market and and and how it can
benefit
them all right seeing no further
questions I want to thank you for your
testimony here this morning thank you
for the committee for giving me the
opportunity I've received a couple of
additional pink cards in the last few
minutes so I'm going to have to lower
the time limit from five minutes to four
minutes and call next on Barbara
Southard who is here she's from Bradford
and she's here representing herself good
morning Miss sou good morning and thank
you for letting me speak today I really
appreciate that
what I want to say is that what we need
to do is start preparing for our
future it's and it's all about economics
really things that are happening in the
world today we can't control that but we
can prepare for it in the words of Ben
Franklin by failing to
prepare you are preparing to
fail so what is happening in the world
that I'm concerned about well starting
in
2026 the EU will be imposing a tariff
it's a carbon border adjustment
mechanism we call cbam just for short
and this will be on carbon intensive
Imports that's like steel fertilizer
aluminum but lots of products will be
added to that as time goes on now
this has tremendous
implications and it's not because we
import all that much from the to the
export that much to the
EU but because other countries are going
to
follow countries like uh well the UK is
planning to do it on in
2027 uh Canada's going to be following
and we do a lot to trade with them
Australia and many other countries
around the world will follow suit and
why would they do that because they
don't want to pay this tariff they don't
they want to they want to the money to
go to their own country and how do they
do that well if they have a carbon
price then they don't have to pay that
tariff well depends on how high their
carbon price is because what what um the
EU will do is it will
subtract what the
exporter has already paid in their own
country so there's a real advantage to
having a carbon price and shoot you
might as well have a border carbon T
attacks while you're doing that uh
and the thing is is that us Industries
are in a great position for this
because their products for example Steel
which is one of the products that is
created in New Hampshire we have lots of
steel
companies when when when they create
this they create it much more
cleanly and so their carbon emissions
per product is much smaller than other
countries it's like three times I mean
China's steel is like three times more
uh carbon intensive than ours so they're
at a what's called carbon
Advantage so what's going to happen is
Industries are going to you know they're
going to start saying hey let's have a
carbon price and let's do a a border
carbon adjustment mechanism that's what
they're going to say it even though we
have Trump who's obviously not really
Pro this kind of thing he's build a
drill baby drill we know that but IND
Industries are going to say
hey we don't want to be paying all this
we want to do this domestically and this
is good for our
industry and so what I'm saying is that
what we need to do is
prepare how exactly could we prepare
well there's a lot of things we could do
uh first of
all our Industries could start trying to
be more
efficient and they could start using
renewable energy and we could try to
make sure we we are using more
Renewables more solar more wind
certainly more wind we have a great
opportunity for
that and and businesses would really do
much better with that because they
wouldn't be paying all this uh this
carbon
fee and
when I'm talking about carbon could you
wrap it up please thank you okay okay so
I really think that we need to provide
some leadership with some carbon I think
a carbon thean dividend right here in
New Hampshire would be great we could
provide leadership to the United States
and hopefully they would follow suit I
appreciate you're listening anybody have
any questions thank you any
questions seeing I want to thank you for
testifying this morning and I'm going to
call next on Dr Steven CLA from
Bedford to represent himself and give us
some testimony thank you we're down to
four minutes I might have to lower that
to three minutes if I keep getting a
dribble of pink cards here good
morning thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak um my name is Dr
Steven CLA I passed out my resume if
you'd like to see my credentials um I'm
currently retired from a long career as
a risk assessor evaluating impacts to
human and ecological Health my job was
essentially to determine the relative
risks of industrial Emissions on human
health and
Wildlife and my clients covered many
different industrial sectors and I
worked in many states with many types of
state and federal Regulatory Agencies as
I spoke to you last week I am here to
voice strong opposition to
hp36 which attempts to modify RSA 12a to
establish a commission to study the
short and long-term impacts of carbon
pricing mechanisms in New Hampshire I'm
an environmental scientist so I can
speak to the underlying causes and
effects that give rise to the perceived
economic losses that I believe will
ensue from what in my professional
judgment would be the irresponsible
formation of a commission to study a
mechanism to punitively put a price on
carbon an abundant element in our
periodic table that is obviously a
necessary building block for life on
this this Earth I can speak to what I
professionally conclude to be potential
environmental impacts of this
fundamental fundamental Elemental
building block pricing carbon and its
many uh bonded forms cannot be measured
the argument for carbon pricing is
fundamentally flawed for the following
reasons the first fundamental flaw is
that the authors of this New Hampshire
Centric Bill endorsed the fantasy that
human effort can somehow put a dent in
the at necess budget for carbon dioxide
within the state of New Hampshire I
provided testimony last week on HB 106
which out outlined the futility of
ascribing carbon dioxide as a driving
variable uh for climate change let alone
the
senselessness of um trying to allocate
costs for this environmental charade
everyone needs to understand what a
minute portion of the atmosphere is
represented by carbon dioxide the answer
being 04 % that's up from the Baseline
of 0.3% over the last 50 years if we get
below
0.2% plant life will alarmingly die off
trying to sequester carbon and
subsequently estimate costs relating to
human activity is kind of like trying to
control the fly population by handing
out fly
swatters which is a good sayway to my
second point and that is the
distribution of carbon in and on the
planet
I just finished teaching my fourth grade
students about the carbon cycle as you
know we breathe in oxygen and breathe
out CO2 while plants breathe in CO2 and
breathe out
oxygen the plants turn the CO2 through
photosynthetic processes into cellulose
and Ox oxygen humans turn cellulose and
oxygen into
CO2 the balance between the two will
naturally shift based on the
distribution of of the two resulting in
a Greener Planet it is a known fact that
most of the us including New Hampshire
is markedly greener than it was a 100
years ago we don't need humans to
balance carbon in the atmosphere let
alone conjure credits at a as a hidden
existence tax on New Hampshire citizens
carbon sequestration in my professional
opinion is a Fool's errand and any
Associated Tax would also be foolishness
my third third and final point is to
highlight the unintended sources of
carbon however harmless they may be that
cancel out any efforts that the
suggested commissions may be attempting
to engineer at society's expense for
example the state of California has
spent Untold billions tearing down dams
which generate a lot of electricity by
the way to protect a small fish but as
we just witnessed the brush fueled fires
in Los Angeles that have resulted from a
host of mismanaged environmental
programs
essentially cancel out Decades of
potential carbon credits by pumping
millions of tons of carbon into the
atmosphere uh I'll I'll just skip over
the last Point here I was talking about
um the senselessness of envir um EV
batteries and the fires at the EV EV
battery um facility last week that they
let burn uncontrolled for days uh and
you're talking about trying to conserve
energy uh through that mechanism is
feudal and I'll just conclude that my
opposition to 306 is based on my
professional experiences spanning 30
years in the field of environmental
science which I would point out hasn't
seen one single prediction made to the
hyper politicized science scientific
consensus Builders come true I strongly
feel that any such commission would be a
house built on a foundation of shifting
sand which like California could be
washed away due to short-sighted
regulatory policies I thank you all uh
for this opportunity to speak and I'll
take any questions okay thank you sir we
appreciate that
questions representative Nutter has
one thank you and thank you for your
testimony today could you tell me what
the difference is between the terms
fossil fuel and
hydrocarbons uh well fossil
fuels hydrocarbons cover anything or
organic anything with carbon in it is a
or carbon attached to another moyy is a
hydrocarbon a fossil fuel in my
definition is something uh that is
pulled out of the ground that was
originally generated from um decaying
fossils which would be coal gas oil that
type of
thing
followup and thank you um for the
follow-up question um well we hear
carbon carbon carbon is it carbon or is
it carbon dioxide which is good for
plants uh well carbon dioxide I think is
is used as a
proxy uh for carbon credits and as I
testified last
week uh carbon
dioxide doesn't amount to a hill beans
as far as uh what affects any potential
Waring on this
planet I'm not sure that answers your
question
but representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr K
for coming in this morning um Mr K
you're somebody who mentions quite a bit
in your testimony that you are a
professional that you you you mentioned
three times that you this is a
professional opinion of yours as a risk
assessor and so I find it quite curious
that you feel that it's futile to
measure measure the impacts of carbon in
the atmosphere which is a something
called the greenhouse effect which has
been studied since at least the 17th
century uh and also attribute um the
fires in California to mismanagement
which seems a controversial and
unscientific opinion and so my question
to you is do you how how do you how do
you account for the fact that the the
vast majority and the preponderance of
scientific evidence points to uh car in
the atmosphere is having you know an
impact on our climate uh do you do you
think it's a conspiracy or where do
where does the IP ttif you don't have to
answer that question uh we're not here
to have a broad discussion about climate
change we're here to discuss House Bill
306 which sets up a commission to study
the impact of carbon pricing so please
confine your questions I agree with you
Mr chair and I I I pardon me if for for
broadening the question out but I felt
like the testimony we're hearing is is
wide ranging and wildly off base in
terms of this bill so I'm I'm just
trying to respond to the testimony that
we
heard representative Vice chair Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair thanks
for taking my question I would like to
get back to the subject matter of this
bill and ask you given all of the
information that is available
from probably thousands of
sources what do you think this
commission could solve or come up with
in terms of the economic impact to the
state of New Hampshire given the subject
matter well as I testified last week I
think we are putting the cart in front
of the horse even even if you believe in
the whole greenhouse gas Paradigm we're
putting the car before the horse there's
no information to go on to create this
commission it's
premature representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Klo for being here with us today
um my question is whether you believe
that there are carbon markets cuz the
bill is about studying whether those
carbon markets are going to affect the
pricing of what people pay here in New
Hampshire for us to be better informed
so do you believe that we have climate
uh not climate not climate car carbon
markets well carbon markets exist but as
Mr cuno testified they don't work in my
public opinion in my own professional
opinion but we still have to deal with
them because they exist right
um I don't think you have to deal with
them the state of New Hampshire doesn't
have to deal with them you know I'm not
an economics professor I'm a scientist I
deal with with the science so I I'm not
sure I can address your question but in
my own personal op opinion I don't think
that we need to deal with carbon markets
and carbon trading as a state to put an
to put an undo tax on the residents um
trying to manipulate the shenanigans
between different energy
Industries okay seeing no more questions
uh I want to thank you for your
testimony thank you and now we're going
to shift gears a little bit I'm going to
call on Megan Stone representing the new
Department of energy to give her to give
us her um interpretation of the
usefulness of house build
306 good morning um Miss Stone and
congratulations on your new job at the
department of energy thank you good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Megan Stone and I'm the legislative leaz
on with the Department of energy
um I will be extremely quick because I
did pass out a letter I partially just
wanted to introduce myself to you all um
the department of energy is neutral on
this bill um however should the
committee move forward uh we just ask
that uh you consider an amendment to add
the department as a member of the
commission uh given the roles given the
Department's role as a regulator and um
its statutory mandate to defend the
public interest um in the Pu filings
made by both electric distribution
companies and natural gas companies um
we just think that it would be important
to decl include the department and for
us be part of the
conversation great thank you very much
for thank you for that do we have a
question representative migy apparently
does I do because when I looked at this
bill I noticed that the commission uh
was seeking to complete its work by
November of
2025 and submit a report to the the
normal Suspects
I if the department were involved in
this when I first looked at that I
thought that there might be required a
longer time frame because oftentimes
these bills are not signed until the
summer so the question to you is um
looking at the um the description of
what the committee will consider would
the department think that that date for
a turnaround time on the report from the
commission be adequate in November um I
believe it should but let me get back to
you on that um I should get back to you
today on that okay thanks all right
thank
you okay thank you Miss Stone thank you
we look forward to uh future visits from
you to the committee next up is Donna
Reen who um didn't list her time
but Town rather but she's um here
to represent Mary Beth Raven is that
correct
yes and I'm I'm a resident of conquered
conquered okay thank
you um and Mary Beth is a resident of
marac and she has
um online
um you have a copy of what I'm I'm
reading for her it was online when she
registered and I apologize for not
bringing
copies um
this is from Mary Beth Raven my name is
Mary Beth Raven and I've had the
privilege of living in marac for over 30
years as residents of New Hampshire we
are all aware that misinformation can
spread easily whether through social
media news outlets or other sources in
this environment it's more important
than ever to ensure we have access to
clear balanced and reliable information
about important issues such as the
potential impact of carbon pricing
mechanisms
one approach to obtaining this
information is to commission a
bipartisan study we know from past
experience this that this is something
our community supports in 2020 I was
proud to help organize a warrant article
that was placed on the ballot in meramac
the article entitled New Hampshire
resolution to take action on climate
pollution called on both state and
federal elected officials to study
carbon pricing
mechanisms the overwhelming support for
this article article which passed with
2,152 votes in favor and
1,115 votes against shows that this
issue has broad backing in our town of
marac two of the members of the St St
committee Representatives n and Thomas
are from marac and I trust they will
honor their commitment to represent the
wishes of their constituents our town
has spoken and we want this study I
encourage all members of the commit to
support this initiative the cost would
be minimal primarily covering mileage
reimbursement for committee members the
value of this study however would be
significant it would provide us with
credible nonpartisan information that
can help us address an important
challenge in our state at the end of the
day this is about working together to
make informed decisions that benefit all
of us what do we stand to lose by coming
together for the greater
good um further note she had was 37
towns have already done cin
pricing and
um thank you from Mary Beth Raven as I
think um many people here probably know
her I also wanted to say that I agree
with what she's saying and
from the years that I've been um
listening and and meeting some of the
SDA members MERS I trust that you would
want to hear both sides and get as much
information you as you can to make a
good decision and hopefully you'll
listen to the
public may may I just make um for myself
something that was in today's conquered
monitor that I would like to share I
won't read it and I have a copy of one
of the Articles and I'll just mention
the other one it should only take a
minute is that okay go ahead quickly
please okay yes um today's conquered
monitor on the cover Granite geek whom
you may know going electric makes sense
with trash like with cars but who's
going to pay um I suggest that um you
read this it's very interesting I
learned from this as well that the
electric if you
if there's a gentleman in cbury who
sponsored a petition to spend $60,000
for electric trash compactor and it was
an easy and
cheap um and if and if that is can go
through then hopefully it'll be a good
role model for other things that'll work
and it
um you can read this for yourself but
basically it's cheaper for them with the
electric when they're replacing to get
the electric trash compactor because it
saves them a lot of time and effort also
Al and money for the um okay thank you
for that the other one is I'll just read
you the title it's what will it take to
commit to a sustainable energy future
and it talks about the grid and how we
need some uh wind power at night because
that's when we can save the most on our
electricity so we won't have brown notes
or black notes Etc thank you for your
time thank you very much next up is Dan
hooperman okay he waves
off could we give that time to John
Gage if we have time we'll see um so
next up is Susan Richmond
chairman Vose and representatives of
this committee I'm Susan Richmond thank
you for your time um before I do my I
think brief remarks I'd just like to
answer a couple comments um so Mr Vose
you chairman Vose you had mentioned does
this make a difference to municipalities
I'm on the uh trash advisory committee
in Durham and in fact yes it does we
needed to buy new garbage trucks which
are hugely expensive and um were
planning to get diesel and then did
further study and realized looking at
projections of what costs would be it
made more sense to get an EV trash uh
trash truck garbage truck and actually
we didn't get two we were hoping to get
two when we realized that logistically
it would be hard to recharge so that was
not just an ideological gohle hog it was
it was really a considered opinion so I
believe that any kind of uh knowing
about the possibility of carbon pricing
helps with any municipal or government
procurement and with business decision
so it's just a wise piece of information
also um as regarding uh representative
Harrington you'd asked why are we even
looking at this given the direction that
the Trump administration's going in my
understanding is Elon Musk actually is
in favor of carbon pricing and you know
who knows what's going to happen with
tariffs worldwide but up until this
moment Europe had been planning and
Canada to put that carbon border
adjustment on our products so again it
would affect business in the us if we
had a kind of Border carbon adjustment
and that's a complicated concept so
thank goodness there could be a study of
that uh last comment um the presumption
from Michael sonunu that any carbon fee
automatically is robbing ing customers
is bizarre because in so many places
that carbon fee whatever money is
collected is just turned around and
return to households and it's simply a
matter of how you set up the bill it is
not pre-ordained um ideally what I've
heard in the United States is that any
kind of carbon fee would be Revenue
neutral that enough would be taken off
to pay the administrative fees about 5
1% to 5% um you know more the first
couple years and then and then nothing
and then households would get money back
and so that has been the experience in
Canada I'm not sure that uh Trudeau
stepping down is entirely the story of
what happened with carbon fee in Canada
my understanding is that a Canadian
carbon pricing system which has been in
place for six years uh under that their
economy has increased 80% of Canadians
receive more in climate action
incentives than they pay an increased
energy cost and their increased
disposable income then then contributes
to a rising GNP and at the same time
carbon emissions have decreased so
there's an organization called Regional
economic modeling Inc or Remy for short
they've provided analysis to both
governmental bodies and to fossil fuel
corporations so they're they are
politically IDE ideologically neutral
and Remy conducted a study on the effect
of a revenue neutral carbon price on the
American economy in other words it would
cost the government nothing and and and
that same kind of giving the money back
to households Remy's analysis found no
economic argument against fee and
dividend it creates jobs grows the
economy saves lives and makes Americans
richer so I'm sharing with you graphs
showing increase in family income which
results in the addition of 2.8 million
jobs over nine years because suddenly
people can afford
healthare um because that's where most
of the money ends up and that's where
most of the new jobs are an increase in
national GDP and then the avoidance of
230,000 premature deaths due to
reduction in air pollutants that often
accompany emissions so you'll see all
those graphs and the stuff that I am
handing you and um I gave representative
Thomas uh statement from a number of uh
I think over 3,000 worldwide economists
of both parties um supporting this as a
economically viable and practical
solution thanks so much for your time
any questions thank you any questions
for Miss
Richmond seeing none we'll turn to the
last speaker of the day and that is Mr
John Gage of Windam representing himself
and Mr Gage you have four
minutes we get four more minutes
from no we have uh a caucus that we need
to get to so four minutes we'll have to
do
I'll tell you what I'll compromise and
give you five how's that thank you thank
you so much chairman Bose and thank you
science technology and energy committee
for hearing my testimony
today I'm John Gage I'm testifying on
behalf of myself today but I am the
state coordinator of citizens climate
Lobby in New Hampshire a national
nonpartisan organization that's working
to create the political will to enable
Congress to pass carbon fee and dividend
legislation but that's not what we're
talking about here today however it is
what gives me a lot of experience I've
been a volunteer for nine years I left
my job six years ago to volunteer
full-time uh so I've studied this
subject I've been in Congress um
lobbying for carbon feing dividend over
60 times and I want to share what I've
learned as a citizen volunteer uh for
federal carbon pricing to help my state
prepare for what I think is inevitable
carbon pricing is spreading around the
world it's tripled in the last 12 or 15
years um prices are rising the EU has
price has tripled in the last 10 years
or so um and Canada is rising um their
carbon fee and dividend bill is
increasing by $15 per ton a year which
is why it's going up it's going up to
send a stronger and stronger price
signal most of the money 90% is going
back to households and 80% of the
families are coming out
ahead
so what is New Hampshire doing given
that carbon
pricing now covers 24% of global fossil
fuel production um countries prices are
rising and Border carbon adjustments are
starting next year I checked Ai and it
said no the EU carbon border adjustment
is not put on hold it's only in phase
one right now which is on paper um the
countries exporters of free polluting
countries have to calculate on paper
what their carbon emissions are and what
it would cost at the border um to put
products into the EU Marketplace the
price starts in 2026 January us
exporters of car of Steel aluminum
cement Plastics will start paying the EU
carbon price next year
the UK starts the following year Japan
after that Australia and Canada are
looking at it the United States is the
only developed country in the world that
doesn't have a carbon
price uh so we're not a leader in this
um but this is what is the most coste
effective way to incentivize investment
and innovation in a clean energy world
if we want to lead the country like we
did in space and computers and the
internet uh we need a market that in
corporate Ates the cost of polluting
into the price of goods so that we get
an efficient market and investors and
businesses can make fully informed
decisions how can the state make fully
informed decisions we can anticipate a
future carbon price today that's what
this commit that's what this study um is
for check out the likelihood of a
federal carbon price about when we
expect it to start about when what price
we expect these are all things that you
know if you live in the carbon world
that I I in inhabit and when we're
making State decisions about how should
we heat our state buildings what should
we use for transportation we don't have
to ban anything but we should anticipate
a price on pollution in the future when
we're buying something that's going to
be in service for 20 or 40 years um
otherwise when there is a federal carbon
price we will find that we're stuck with
strained assets which would have been
prevented but they are preventable right
now um and this study is how to do that
simply asking please take a look at
let's evaluate the likelihood of a
carbon price the impacts on New
Hampshire and steps we can take here to
do proper risk management um it might
not be 100% chance but businesses
hundreds of businesses and some states
are already doing this anticipating a
future carbon price and the decisions
they're making now um to be strategic to
save taxpayer dollars uh and somebody
asked what can we do about businesses um
they're probably not paying attention to
Global carbon markets um the state can
let them you know inform them this study
can be a blueprint here's what we know
what's going on we've checked it out
we've had the Bia and clean energy New
Hampshire and and legislators from both
parties and we've looked at the World
Bank State and trends of carbon pricing
report we've looked at what's going on
in Congress um we've thought about how
we manage our state and this is a this
is our best advice for properly handling
uh the potential for a federal carbon
price in New
Hampshire okay thank you questions for
Mr Gage
representative Corman has
one thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Gage for being here um you said that
uh carbon pricing is the most effect
cost effective way to reduce carbon and
I know that citizens climate Lobby is
very big on that mechanism um what's the
basis for that uh opinion yeah sure
there was a recent uh study that looked
at all of the countries
uh their their climate policies uh and
many of them did not produce very much
results the successful countries uh in
reducing emissions were the ones that
had carbon pricing included in their
policy mix uh I can forward you that
report after this meeting um but it's
not only the most cost effective it is
very powerful and there was a question
about whether carbon pric works it
depends on the price obviously if you
know Reggie had a price of $5 per ton of
CO2 for 10 years that's not a
significant price signal to drive change
um if when Reggie went in they had
instead done a carbon fee in dividend
which Rises by $10 per ton of CO2 a year
we would have a carbon price of $100 per
ton now which is a significant price
signal which is more than the EU or
Canada has and The Bu the coal plant and
bow would have been stopped 5 years ago
because it would have been uncompetitive
in providing electricity to the grid um
so it is the most powerful cost
effective and efficient and
comprehensive because it instead of
picking one particular technology or um
regulation to impose it simply sends a
price signal through the whole economy
um but that's you know it works the main
point though is it's happening spreading
and and us exporters are going to start
paying it to more and more countries so
this commission the study commission is
to say look we're probably going to end
up paying a carbon price at some point
what should we do now um to to make the
best of you know to do risk assessment
but make the best of it if it happens U
we know what those things are but we
could produce a report and advise our
businesses our our state leaders um
share information that is really
fundamental to managing the economy of
New
Hampshire okay additional
questions representative
reels thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Gage for being here um you know not
withstanding what you just said about
Reggie and the the
low $5 per ton price that it started out
with we we had testimony and were given
graphs last week by folks from the
utilities and and the iso New England
that showed over the last 15 years since
the Advent of regie
that um the much
lower carbon fuel natural gas fired
power plants have steadily gained market
share uh in the regions uh in the region
and that the coal and oil fired power
plants have essentially been driven out
do you think that that is a do you think
that Reggie is a
uh good demonstration of the power of
subtle even subtle price signals to
change uh the carbon intensity of an of
an economy I do it was a good Regional
or you know Regional effort uh the
problem with um pricing carbon at a
state or Regional level is you can't do
the Border carbon adjustment
and so your businesses um have a
competitive disadvantage uh in the cost
of production and energy generally oh uh
I heard earlier somebody said a carbon
tax is a tax on energy that is
completely wrong that's a fossil fuel
talking point a carbon fee is a polluter
fee so those energy sources that don't
pollute carbon don't pay the fee um it's
a it's a fee on polluters it's not a tax
on energy
uh that is a tactic that we keep hearing
over and over again to scare us from
doing something that would not be good
for the fossil fuel industry but this is
in our best interest I just wanted to
mention there's a two-face game the
fossil fuel industry plays the first
handout that I gave you uh is a list of
quotes from websites today from fossil
fuel producers oil and gas uh saying we
accept the science of climate change
from our pollution and we support carbon
pricing because it's the economist gold
standard way to reduce this
pollution representative Kaplan has a
question yes uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you uh Mr Gage for coming in again
this morning uh I actually have a
two-part question the first one is a
simple yes or no do you find it uh as
interesting as I do that this uh carbon
pricing mechanism was originally a
republican idea based on on the
principle that the market should be uh
the deciding factor in in determining
our our Energy Mix and secondly what do
you account how do you account for the
fact that it's become such a partisan
issue okay the first part right James
Baker and George Schultz came out with a
um a steadily Rising carbon fee reate
all the money back to households and use
a border adjustment to um protect us
producers as well as hold other
uh free polluting countries accountable
so yes I do think that's important to
note this is a business-friendly
conservative approach that we're trying
to get Congress to do um from the state
perspective however carbon pricing
happens is tough to say uh the treasury
secretary nominee of President Trump is
Mr Gage Scot thank you I appreciate you
answering that question but it's not
directly related to the subject of the
bill what was the second which is a
study
commission uh which is determined to be
quite expensive so representative McGee
how about the second part of my question
could he try to answer that I mean was
there a second part there was yeah go
ahead how do you account for the fact
that a carbon pricing mechanism has
become so politicized and so
partisan yeah that has nothing to do
with the bill I can just say I don't
think we need to discuss that
representative McGee do you have a
question that's relevant to the bill I
do thank thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Gage for coming out again um from
your testimony and also from what you've
presented here uh would you be able to
answer the question of whether you think
there is a need for us it seems like
there are lots of questions and also
lots of opinions from people about uh
what we could and couldn't be doing
should and shouldn't be doing but what
it leads me to believe is that we don't
have uh we don't have enough answers
amongst us here in order to be doing the
business of the state which is making
decisions around things like pricing for
whether it's RPS pricing or um or Reggie
pricing that type of thing we can't
really participate in those debates and
we can't be making good decisions if we
don't have more information than we do
today would you agree with
that yes I agree um there are some good
bills this okay you answered the
question the proxy carbon pricing bill
we appreciate your your being here and
uh I think it's time to move on we have
other business to conduct we all need to
be back here at 1:00 for another public
hearing so I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill
306 and encourage you to enjoy your
lunch and we'll see you at 1:00 Mr
chairman can we get the blue sheet and
online numbers please yes the online
number is support 111 oppose live and
representative PL if you could give us
the blue sheet
numbers thank you represent VES could I
get them after lunch okay we'll get
those for you after lunch and I'm sorry
Mr chair can you repeat those
numbers 111 to
5 thank
you
e
e e
could you take your seats please we will
begin
momentarily
e e
okay time to resume our activity here
this uh
afternoon science technology and energy
for the
21st
okay yeah we've had had that issue in
the
past and I don't remember what we did
about it do you
remember yeah I mean if you put it back
further that would help but then last
year or last term you told me we weren't
allowed to touch
that that's true that is true that is
true all right we're going to have to
live with it for now yeah okay all right
let's get started here so so we are uh
I've just opened a public hearing on
House Bill 95- FN requiring the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op to regularly
file a certificate of deregulation with
the Public Utilities Commission and I
want to call on the prime sponsor of the
bill representative Wendy Thomas to
introduce the bill to
us thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee uh for the
record I am Wendy Thomas and I represent
the town of marac and I'm here to
introduce House Bill
995 first a certificate of deregulation
is a formal document or legal
acknowledgement issued by a governing
Authority that signifies an entity such
as an electric utility or cooperative
operates under a deregulated framework
in the context of electricity markets it
typically means the utility or
cooperative is not bound by certain
regulatory requirements such as price
controls or service obligations that
apply to fully regulated entities
instead it may function in a competitive
market place allowing customers more
choice and
flexibility the last time the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op filed a
certificate of deregulation was 24 years
ago requiring the New Hampshire uh Co-op
to file a certificate of deregulation
every 3 years could be beneficial for
its members for several reasons
filing a certificate ensures that the
Cooperative regularly reviews its
regulatory status and communicates its
operational choices to members this
promotes transparency allowing members
to understand how decisions align with
their interests being unregulated has
served the co-op well and while I don't
anticipate any change to that status the
members have a right to be heard with
regard to the direction that the co-op
is
heading as a cooperative
NHC is member owned regularly filing
this certificate ensures that the
leadership remains accountable to its
members by providing them with
consistent updates on the organization's
structure and Regulatory
alignment electric markets and
regulations evolve over time a trienal
review and filing process encourag The
Cooperative to reassess whether
deregulation continues to be the best
approach for its members given given
current mark market
conditions the filing process could
include member consultations giving
members a say in whether deregulation
aligns with their needs this strengthens
Democratic participa participation
within the
Cooperative by mandating regular reviews
the bill ensures that the co-op is not
locked into a regulatory model that
could that may no longer serve its
members best interests providing a
safeguard against decisions that could
negatively impact rates or service
quality
quity with advances in renewable energy
energy storage and grid Technologies The
Cooperative must adapt to maintain
affordability and
reliability requiring periodic
re-evaluation ensures the cooperative's
regulatory framework remains suitable
for the evolving energy
landscape the recurring requirement
promotes a culture of long-term planning
and strategic thinking within the
Cooperative benefiting members by
fostering consistent efforts to optimize
operations and costs this is not in any
way a punitive request instead it is a
transparency request so that all Co-op
members can remain on the same page by
supporting this bill members and
stakeholders excuse me ensure that the
Cooperative remains aligned with its
mission to provide reliable and
affordable electricity while adapting to
the needs of its membership andk Market
changes thank you and I'll take any
questions thank you representative one
quick question are you a member of the
co-op I am not okay thank you uh
representative Vice chair Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question uh did
the new did the New England Co-op
request this bill no
no follow follow up and is there an
issue that you disc discovered that
resulted in this bill being required to
submit for some maybe some unknown issue
that didn't exist or you weren't aware
of um the idea for the bill came from a
a column that was written by our
consumer Advocate uh identifying that
the last time the regulations uh had
been filed were 24 years ago and there
there was a little bump with the uh the
board members uh either last year or the
year
before representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question my question
is around the cycle for three years if
there's a reason for that or if uh it
could be you know five years or how' you
come up with three hey Google what's the
average uh term of a board member so
three years is the average term of a
board member across the board I mean
across the board that was I didn't mean
to say that
um that's the average term and so that's
why um that's why that that uh time
frame is in
there all right seeing no more questions
we want to thank you representative for
introducing this legislation next we'll
hear from the New Hampshire Electric
Co-op and I'll call Mr Michael Jennings
who is uh a member of uh the
co-ops regulatory
uh regime and William Darcy who is the
chairman of the board of the co-op so
Gentlemen please let us know what you
think of this
Bill thank you chairman Vose and
honorable members of the House science
technology and energy committee I am
Michael Jennings I am the interum
president and CEO and with me today I
have William Darcy the chair of of our
board of directors I am here today to
testify an opposition of House Bill
95 so the New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative opposes House Bill 95
because we see it as unnecessary and it
could add additional costs to both rate
payers and members of The
Cooperative as we discussed last week
NHC is different than the other
utilities we were founded in 1939 to
provide electric service to the most
Rural and underserved parts of New
Hampshire that the for-profit utilities
wouldn't serve so we're a nonprofit that
is democratically controlled by its
members who directly elect our board of
directors our members are the owners of
the system and we in return return
operating margins to our membership in
the form of capital credits as a
Cooperative we exist to meet the needs
needs of our members and as a result New
Hampshire Broadband LLC is the
for-profit wholly owned subsidiary we
created in 2020 in direct response to
that
membership we oppose House Bill 95 for
the following reasons firstly that the
members of the New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative already possess the ability
to choose whether or not to be
regulated members of NHC affirmed their
desire to be deregulated in une 2000 and
currently possess the authority as
democratically controlled organization
to reaffirm that choice or choose
otherwise via bylaw petition during our
annual
election secondly it's important to
remember that our members overwhelmingly
supported our deregulation so NHC exists
to serve its members who have been very
clear about their views on this issue
when this issue was last raised at our
annual meeting and 2000 nearly 95% of
the membership voted to stay or to
become
deregulated also the proposed
legislation could cost New Hampshire
rate payers an estimated
$65,000 if the Cooperative failed to
file that certificate of deregulation
this bill would make NHC subject to
regulation by the p and the Pu estimates
it would cost an additional
$65,000 to hire addition staff to meet
this
obligation if the Cooperative filed a
certificate of
deregulation it would add costs to
members in terms of the annual election
as well so in order to reaffirm the
certificate a deregulation The
Cooperative would need to spend
additional money and encourage a super
majority vote of its members at an
election every three years these costs
would unfortunately be borne by members
of The Cooperative
it would also increase costs to The
Cooperative members if we became
regulated by the Pu the
$65,000 was related to the Pu costs the
New Hampshire Electric Cooperative would
also have to hire additional staff at a
very considerable cost as well to work
with the Public Utilities Commission a
cost that would also have to be born by
the members of the
cooperative and lastly ulation by the Pu
would stifle the ability of the
Cooperative to be responsive to its
members and HC has demonstrated numerous
times over the years an ability to be
nimble and Innovative on a variety of
matters including power purchases time
of day use rates by members and New
Hampshire Broadband regulation by the Pu
would hamper this ability to be
Innovative and flexible the decision to
provide Broadband is just another
example of how the Cooperative has been
Innovative over the years since most
regulated Electric utilities have not
even stepped foot into that
business and I will hand it over to uh
bill as
well thank you chairman V and members of
the committee I'm the chair of the New
Hampshire Electric Cooperative I'm also
chair of their Broadband subsidiary New
Hampshire Broadband I've never appeared
before you so I want to give you a
little introduction in addition to those
positions I'm chair of the town of
Benton's Board of Selectmen uh most
people don't know where Benton is it's
so small that we don't even have a staff
so I'm also the defacto town manager uh
most people don't know where it is but
hikers do because it's the home of Mount
musak uh which is the Western most 4,000
footer in uh New
Hampshire I wanted to supplement uh
Mike's testimony uh which has most of
the points by uh pointing out a number
of things about uh uh about this but I
did want to go back I I do have some
regulatory background back in Conneticut
where I came I was a consumer advocate
for a number of years under a odd
statute that had me representing only
electric and telec Communications uh um
customers I then became director of
regulation for the Connecticut pu in
charge of electric telephone water and
gas customers the important thing about
uh
regulation is I think and one of the
unintended consequences is it
uh Mike noted Broadband uh in 200
20 uh the members by petition it was not
did not come from the board of directors
did not come from staff uh said we want
to do Broadband uh uh we want you to do
broadband and provide it uh to members
uh what happened is uh the that passed
uh with a 64% vote of members the very
next meeting of the board of directors
after that
election uh
the board decided to uh obey the will of
the members and to get into the
Broadband business which was fortuitous
because that was the month that Governor
cunu uh issued an
opportunity uh for uh grants under what
is called the cares program uh the catch
was they had to spend the money uh by
the end of the year uh so very few
people actually stepped up to the bar uh
NHC did do that but if we were regulated
never would have happened uh because you
would have had to go to the Pu start a
proceeding to be able to uh get an
authorization to get into this new risky
competitive area and it never would have
happened and that Grant in our
successful execution of that Grant is
why
uh NHC is now providing service to
thousands of broadband customers
including myself in towns which had no
chance of getting a cable company or
anybody else to be able to provide that
service to them uh and we would not have
even gotten the grants that we got we
got federal grants we got northern
border Grant we got a $50 million uh
Grant from uh Bea it never would have
happened unless we established our
credentials our ability to build execute
and service and provide service so
that's one of the UN unanticipated
consequences of Regulation that never
would have happened another one that
that members may may recall that a
couple years ago when Energy prices
spiked uh people looked around and they
and they saw that NHC actually had lower
rates than the regular utilities so it
started an examination well why could
this be well what was revealed is there
we did things differently in two uh
important respects uh one is that we had
more Market exposure something that none
of the other utilities had because they
were they were fixed in a sixth month
going out to bid with what's called ibts
but they're energy marketers we did that
for for most of our our as well but we
had a a considerable Taste of the of the
market and that caused to to suppress
the the race the other thing we did was
we had some longer term and Midterm
contracts some people refer to that as
ladin but the combination of that
especially when rates are spiking is you
entered into those earlier contracts
when rates weren't so high so that had
an effect on moderating our rates as
well so I bring that up only because
it's an example if we were regulated we
would have been doing things the way
ever source unitel and Liberty uh was
doing it because we weren't regulated we
were able to find a different way and
therefore serve as an example to the
other Utilities in the puc we've also
had Innovations in other areas we were
the first ones in in New Hampshire to
have Smart Meters Ami we've done some
pilot programs in in various areas some
success some failures but again it
provides a an area to to look at and say
you know maybe they did it right maybe
they not maybe we ought to look at it so
I think it provides it's valuable that
we be deregulated and provide those
benefits I think to all of New Hampshire
thank
you okay gentlemen thank you for giving
us your perspective on the legislation
now we'll turn to questions and
representative Michael Harrington has
one
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question having listened to
this I'm trying to figure out it seems
as if there's a solution that's trying
to find a problem is there anything that
this bill would allow you to do or not
to do that you couldn't already do now
under your present
Charter no that is correct there is
nothing um additional in this bill that
our members can already do already thank
you more questions representative rol
has one thank you thank you Mr chairman
um thank you gentleman for being here
today
um in a in in a lot but not all of your
testimony but a lot of your
testimonies seemed to be
discussing this bill as if it
contains a requirement as if
it's going to require that you become a
regulated utility which you're not not
now I should have I wanted to preface my
remarks by saying I'm a real I'm a big
admirer of the the Electric Cooperative
um everything that that you guys do uh
not the least of which uh in a previous
professional life I worked with the New
Hampshire uh one of your biggest
customers the North Conway water
Precinct to uh install that megawatt of
solar and I was impressed all along in
terms of how they were working with you
policies that made that possible anyway
I just wanted to say I'm an admirer of
the co-op but a lot of your testimony
was speaking as if this bill was going
to be requiring you to become regulated
uh and it's not I mean I plain reading
of the bill says that it would require
you to go through a process to
essentially
uh discuss certify why you should
continue to be unregulated so in that
vein is wouldn't it be possible for you
to look at a requirement like this and
perhaps the
period the time period could be changed
so that it wasn't three years maybe
every five years uh wouldn't it provide
you an opportunity to essentially brag
on
yourself and describe not only for your
members but for the state as a whole uh
why being unregulated ated and operating
as a Cooperative allows you to do many
of the things you just talked about be
Innovative you
know um ladder your your supply
contracts have Smart Meters offer your
customers time of use rates all those
things that the our
regulated friends don't seem to be able
to do uh you could dis you could brag on
yourselves every five years and help
inform not just like I said you're
members but uh the whole state this
committee uh the advantages that you
that you enjoy and the benefits that
they have thank you for that question
representative uh I think our reaction
is because under existing
legislation both the statutes in place
now and our
bylaws explicitly give the members the
ability to by fil on a petition to do
exactly what this bill requires in 24
years we haven't gotten a peep of
members suggesting we want you to be
regulated I mean we haven't got a single
petition uh on that subject so the
reaction that we have by addressing the
downsides of Regulation is this bill in
in essence says that's not good enough
the will of the members the legislature
and the governor by signing this would
be in saying in essence that we think
you should be
regulated uh because otherwise uh the
the existing power of the members
through our own democratic system allows
it so this wouldn't be necessary as to
toot in our own horn we have
monthly uh newsletters that we send to
all all members uh describing what we do
for them uh you know encourages uh
conservation tell them the benefits that
we have we're tooting our horns on a
regular basis we have a whole section
that of our our
organization uh for communications that
that that that that tell that so we see
the only
only only effect of this is to add cost
to us on elction and asking the members
to do something that they already have
the right to do
thank
you seeing no further questions I want
to thank you gentlemen for stopping by
oh sorry representative F uh thank you
CH no apologies that was a last late one
uh thank you for of being back with us
uh as a member of the Electric
Co-op would the PC uh you PC yeah pu
thank you
be involved in what we have now
as
um putting in to the next hire for um
committee to donate to the community
would they be in there involved in that
and would they have been involved with
Molton Burrow's so
array thank
you yeah thank you thank you for the
question when you're asking about
donating to the community are you
referring to the uh cooperatives um
nonprofit
portion well not the nonprofit they're
all it's all
nonprofit yes the few cents up to the
nearest Dollar the foundation The Round
Up thank
you that's a great question I I don't
know that I'm prepared to discuss that
today on what the implications would be
to the extent of of the puc's regulation
there but um that is something that the
Cooperative has had a lot of flexibility
to to implement due to his deregulated
status and and being able to give back
to the
community okay seeing no further
questions thank you gentlemen appreciate
it next we'd like to hear
from the state consumer Advocate Mr Don
cre to give us his perspective on this
legislation good morning or good
afternoon actually Mr Mr cre nice to
have you
back good afternoon uh chairman Vose
honorable members of the committee uh as
you just heard my name is Donald cree
and for almost nine years now I've had
the honor of serving as this state's
consumer Advocate this is my first
opportunity to testify this session so
uh for those of you who might be
unfamiliar with me uh I lead the very
small independent state agency that
fights for the interests of the state's
residential utility customers most most
of our work happens in connection with
cases at the Public Utilities Commission
but not all of it one area of particular
interest to us is the New Hampshire
Electric Cooperative which of course is
one of the states for electric utilities
but as you already heard the only one
that is almost completely beyond the
scrutiny of the Public Utilities
Commission the reason is that back on
June 6th 2000 almost a quarter century
ago and pursuant to what was then a
recently enacted statute the up filed
what the law refers to as a certificate
of deregulation with the commission uh
in essence the filing of and I should
say that the that certificate was filed
because the members of the co-op back in
2000 voted by a super majority to
authorize its filing in essence the
filing of that certificate means the Pu
no longer approves the co-op's rates in
terms of service and the logic for doing
that as you've already heard is very
compelling the Pu exists to serve as the
Arbiter of the interests of the utility
shareholders and the utility customers
but at an Electric Co-op the
shareholders and the customers are the
same people the customers themselves
known in Cooperative parlament as
members don't just own their utility
they also control it through a board of
directors that the members elect I
really love that I love it as a rate
payer Advocate letting the rate payers
control their own utility without the
government getting in the way I love it
as a long time cooperator I've served as
the president of the board of the
nation's second biggest Cooperative
grosser which happens to be based right
here in New Hampshire and I've also been
the president of the board of the
Cooperative fund of the Northeast which
has lent millions and millions of
dollars to co-ops of all types and I
love it as a fan of democracy so in the
name of democracy House Bill 95 makes a
small tweak to the applicable law in the
interest of enhancing the hallowed
Cooperative principle of Democratic
member control it has been a long time a
very long time since the members of the
New Hampshire elector Cooperative have
had a chance to vote on whether their
Co-op is doing a good enough job serving
its members that oversight by the Pu
isn't necessary House Bill 95 would
require the co-op if it wants to stay
deregulated to put that Quest into the
co-op membership every 3 years and yes
you could think whether three years is
the right period period uh it makes
sense for the reason that representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas gave that it
coincides with the average board term
another period might be four years that
coincides with the typical period
between rate cases at regulated
utilities or you could use some other
period but you might wonder why come
forward with an idea like this now
that's already been asked well to the
alarm of many the New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative has been in the news of late
last year in the wake of the co-ops
annual board meeting and and its annual
Board election uh the two long serving
women on the board one a former board
president and the other a former board
vice president resigned and they did so
rather clamorously alleging that there
was a climate of sexism and bullying in
the co-op's boardroom the co-op's CEO
who happened to be the first woman to
serve in that role prais the two
resigning board members for their
courage and their integrity
and she has since tendered her
resignation after just two years on the
job that's why you heard from her male
successor this this afternoon that was
really troubling to us at the OCA so I
asked the Pu to investigate the Pu
declined noting correctly that a
certificate of deregulation is on file
and
effective why is House Bill 95 a mere
tweak because current law allows the
members of the co-op to ask for a vote
on revoking that certificate of
deregulation House Bill 95 would make
such a revote automatic every 3 years
honorable legislators think about
everything that has happened in the
electric industry since the co-op filed
that certificate of deregulation 25
years ago restructuring distributed
generation Community power aggregation
changes in wholesale electricity market
and at the Electric Co-op an intriguing
but in some circles very controversial
foray into rural Broadband deployment
and let me just say in response to the
testimony I just heard that regulation
by the Pu would not have stopped the
Electric Co-op from operating a
Broadband subsidiary it would have
assured that electric service doesn't
subsidize broadband service or is
dragged down by it in the event that
broadband service is not financially
successful as somebody who has closely
observed and cultivated a good
relationship with the Electric Co-op
since I took office here here's my
prediction for what will happen if House
Bill 95 becomes law the board and
management of the co-op will every time
it comes up make a persuasive case to
the membership that their utility is
still worthy of that exemption from pu
oversight and the members will renew
that certificate of deregulation every
time the question comes up but requiring
that question to come up periodically
will be healthy for this utility and its
customers and it just might serve as a
good example for those those of us who
are not fortunate enough to own the
electricity or the electric utility that
serves us I think that's all I have to
say so thank you for hearing my
testimony and of course I'd be happy to
answer any questions that chairman V
might be willing to
entertain thank you very much appreciate
it I'd like to just sort of paraphrase
your argument in a single sentence if I
could you think that the turnover in New
Hampshire Electric Co-op customers and
board members justifies a more frequent
endorsement of
deregulation Yes actually that's the
point I didn't make that but it's sort
of implicit right I mean in the last 25
years there's been enough turnover in
the core of members who are uh dependent
on the electric Co for service that
really relying on a vote that took place
in June of or in the spring of 2000
doesn't really represent the current
body of New Hampshire Electric Co-op
members thank you additional
questions representative Swanson has
some so uh just to be clear uh there's
never you know there was a deregulation
certificate initially and there hasn't
been one since and there won't be
another one unless there is this
requirement put in place yes but uh as I
think either Mr Jennings or Mr Darcy
pointed out to you the co-op's bylaws do
authorize the uh Co-op to place that
question before the membership again on
Petition of a certain number of members
I think it might be I think it's a
hundred it might be more uh so all I'm
suggesting to you and representative
Tomas was kind enough to credit me with
the idea for this bill I think that's
true is making that revote automatic I
think it's democracy enhancing to do
that representative McGee has question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
coming here and testifying for us and
helping to explain some of these uh
issues to us um my question is around
the money that was mentioned in the
testimony from the co-op um they
mentioned that 605,000 was an estimate
from the Pu for um what it would cost
the Public Utilities Commission to I
guess engage additional resources in
order to manage an additional regulated
utility but this bill doesn't this
doesn't uh result in them becoming a
regulated utility so I think it's a bit
of a stretch to say that there's any
money really associated with it although
the testimony from the co-op did mention
that there would be a cost to the
elections themselves which might be an
argument for it being on a longer time
frame than a shorter time frame do you
do you have any sense yourself on what
kind of cost would be associated with
that because I think most things are
done electronically now so I don't I
don't know how they vote
uh the the the additional cost to the
co-op would be zero because the co-op
already has an annual election this
presumably would take place as part of
that uh the co-op is as it testified is
already trying to be as responsive and
interactive and transparent as it can so
presumably the incremental cost of
having to make an argument every four or
three or five years that yes we remain
worthy of non-regulation would be zero
they already have people to do that uh
and as far as the additional cost of the
Pu of Regulation I I want to be
forthright regulation imposes costs I
mean and if I were the CEO of the
Electric Co-op if I had to make the case
to my members that they should not
revoke or resend the certificate of
deregulation that's that's one of the
points I would make for
sure follow up the only other thing I
would ask is what do you think the
likelihood is that the membership would
vote to become a regulated ility because
I if I were in there uh in service area
I don't think I ever would vote that way
so I don't I don't think it's likely you
know so I'm just wondering if you have
any idea I I agree with you
representative McGee that it's very
unlikely again what I'm trying to say is
I think it's really healthy for the
co-op to have to make that case every
few years and I fully expect that the
members if the management of the co-op
and the board of the co-op is as
responsive to member needs as they claim
they are then of course the membership
ship will overwhelmingly say nope we
like things just the way they
are representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair um so the
issue that you have identified as a
causitive factor for this bill is
turnover of officers at at the
co-op none no issue like Broadband costs
of
impacting
electric uh costs or nothing associated
with the physical Services provided by
the co-op have been adversely impacted
just this turnover issue is that is that
the basis and if it is why is a an
election like this required to address
that
problem uh with respect representative
Bernardi I I don't agree with the
premise of your question uh turnover at
the Board of an elected uh turnover on
the board of an Electric Co-op uh which
of course elects its board members from
among the membership of the overall
utility is a natural consequence of that
democracy what I'm expressing or what I
expressed concerns about was turmoil in
the electric co-op's boardroom of such
intensity that it led to veteran members
of the board both of whom who helped
lead the board and both of whom were
women and areen women to resign publicly
and loudly alleging that they were
dealing with a climate of bullying and
sexism and I think it's fair to say that
that climate of bullying and sexism is
causally related to the decision of the
female CEO of the Electric Co-op to
leave and relocate her family to another
state after just two years on the job as
to whether any of that had any
relationship to the actual merits of
what the Electric Co-op does I'm quite
certain that it did but I don't have
access to that why do I not have access
to that because the cohop isn't
regulated any additional questions
representative schneller thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony uh just a question did any of
this turnover or
turmoil uh lead to complaints of higher
rates I don't know the answer to that
question thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you Mr Cree for being here
my pleasure thank you and next I'll call
up Alex spidel from the Public Utilities
Commission to give us the commission's
perspective on this
legislation good afternoon chairman Vos
and members of the committee thank you
for having me uh this may be an unusual
thing to here down in Washington DC
you'd never hear an Federal agency
wherein a proposed piece of legislation
open a potential door for regulation of
a new company or a new industry um and
down there in Washington they wouldn't
say we're not interested in that but the
commission does oppose this bill and
we're not interested in taking this
approach and we would prefer that the
Cooperative remain uh deregulated as it
currently is under the author of the
legislature and its current deregulation
certificate so there's a few reasons I
know there's a lot of things on the dock
today Mr chairman I'll be short uh in a
nutshell The Cooperative is deregulated
under the authority of the legislature
because much like a municipal utility
where you have say at Manchester
Waterworks you have the board of
Alderman and the mayor pick the director
of the Manchester Waterworks the owners
of the utility are the customers of the
utility so there's a line of democratic
account ability up through the board of
directors and then the management team
so that's a little bit different from an
investment owned utility that has a
classic Monopoly power over the
customers and the shareholders of the
utility pick uh the management team
there so there's it's a little bit
different but the nutshell is that um
there's a few issues with this uh we
have heard the testimony in the
description that the hypothetical cost
of 600,000 that was presided presented
by the Pu in the fiscal note is not a
100% guarantee that that will happen we
just offered that as the likely cost of
doing business if the Cooperative were
to vote for regulation by the Pu P
because uh we're at capacity right now
we have a staff of 12 line employees and
three Commissioners and we're at
capacity right now we have a r Cas cycle
every year for major utilities we have
many small utility filings coming in all
the time so we just wanted to alert to
the legislature that if the Cooperative
joined us as a full-fledged electric
utility um there's always teething
troubles associated with potential uh
filing requirements they would have to
move from a I understand from some
research that they're on a roughly
twomon lead time for a rate change
they'd have to go to a full year rate
case cycle they'd have toar learn how to
file certain Financial forms with us and
there's teething troubles that come with
that kind of process every time uh and
so in general what we would recommend is
that we leave things that the way they
are with the Cooperative we see no need
or necessity under the any theor
regulation to take control of the
cooperative's Affairs through
regulation and so um we would um just
leave it at that thank
you thank you question for the Pu Tom
PL thank you chair and thank you for
coming in um does the
Pu presently have any interaction with
the New Hampshire co-op we have a
limited role in the realm of Energy
Efficiency so as you know the
legislature has a very prominent role in
energy efficiency regulations since 2021
but as part of that the Cooperative has
always interacted with us by making
periodic Energy Efficiency rate
adjustment filings and that's actually
kind of based on a mechanical Adder
right now for their expense but they do
make them with the commission and also
the department of energy I do believe
interacts with the Cooperative on the
field of safety regulation for their
physical
plant representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh pertaining
to the uh regulation d regulation of New
Hampshire co-op uh two years ago
beginning of the last term we had
extremely bad weather we had and the
rates were extremely high and if I
recall from earlier earlier that term
last term that the um electrical rates
of the co-op were significantly cheaper
than the the other organizations down
here in the South and the New Hampshire
co-op I believe was able to Lad or hedge
against pricing does reg if it would
become uh regulated would that have any
effect on the price that the co-op is
able to offer to its rate
payers I would like to say in general
that uh if anything The Cooperative was
able to teach the commission about what
to do uh in the wake of the 2022 Market
Panic rather than the other way around
and if you don't mind me turning the
question a little bit around Mr
representative because what happened at
that time is we had an investigation at
the commission regarding the market
prices for electricity
and the Cooperative was kind enough to
they had no obligation to do so but its
leadership was kind enough to offer us a
response to one of our inquiries that we
also made of the Municipal Utilities
around the state like Littleton Power
and Light for instance and each of those
gave us very good information about
their market-based procurement process
lading was investigated and considered
but the utilities themselves including
eversource also said that there's mixed
outcomes from lading they've done it in
Southern New England and it's all about
the timing so it's kind of like a coin
flip game a lot of probabilities if you
time it well so that the lading offers
you a good price because of when you
bought versus when you are exposed to
the market it can work but it can go the
other way around so I'm trying to
summarize some very complex things but
what the re-regulation would do is it
would move the Cooperative from a
structure where it's members vote on the
rate increases to where you essentially
have the Pu having to adjudicate
everything and it could be a little
clunkier okay additional questions M
representative rolds thank you Mr chair
uh I guess given your that that answer
that you just gave representative
Summers I want to reprise my my question
to the co-op's
leadership don't you think that
I'm sorry you're supposed to ask a
question of yeah yeah I'm I'm gonna ask
the staff staff person from the
Pu uh requiring the
co-op
to
refile to remain
unregulated every three or perhaps every
five years don't you
think given what you just said about
them educating you don't you think think
that this the process of refiling could
provide a
regular opportunity for them to do that
uh to distill their you know monthly
member reports into a triennial or an
every fiveyear report on why being
unregulated is great and the practices
that they're able to uh engage in that
keep their rates low and service levels
High um Mr representative I would say
that the Pu is confident that the com
The Cooperative can manage its own
Affairs as it is we don't really need to
hear from them they did that of their
own free will and I think that it could
be sort of um a resource strain I think
they're pretty thinly staffed themselves
they're they're a tight operation and so
if they have to essentially run the
equivalent of a political campaign every
3 years to say we don't want to be
regulated given what's happening in the
World At
Large um they would be distracted I
think from their core mission of serving
their membership and so we don't have
anything to do with them directly we
just wish them well and we're keying off
of the fact that we want to make clear
that we're not eager to seize uh
jurisdiction over this unregulated
Cooperative utility that's we thought
that was
important okay seeing no further
questions I want to thank you for being
here to testify we appreciate that and
since I have no more pink cards on this
uh issue I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 95
FN and I will now open the public
hearing on House Bill
166 and I believe that Representative
Keith Ammon is going to introduce this
bill to us so I will call Representative
Ammon forward so that we can learn about
House Bill 166 good morning or good
afternoon representative Ammon
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the science technology and energy
committee so I'm I'm pinch hitting for
representative
Edwards uh so I'll defer questions to
maybe hopefully experts behind
me so this bill is a study commission
Bill House Bill 166 establishes a
committee to review internet service
provider infrastructure transition plan
from copper to fiber
so this is this is my understanding on
the bill uh I'm going to use air quotes
here uh a
whistleblower from an ISP came forward
and said that there is an inevitable
progression from copper to fiber in the
in in with isps but that there's some uh
market dynamics that are making these
efforts to convert from copper to fiber
potentially UNS sustainable or
potentially disruptive to the market we
all know how how important internet is
it's critical
infrastructure so representative Edwards
was contacted by an employee familiar
with the plan I don't know the ISP I
don't know the
employee but the employee stated a
concern that the plan is obviously too
aggressive and that if attempted as
intended it might lead to outages
particularly in rural areas and or call
Cost spikes for individual residences to
buy in on earlier
conversion and so what this study
commission if you look at line 13 the
duties it's basically a
sunlight exercise where the isps would
be asked to come in and discuss their
plan there would be representation or
there' be consultation with the Pu and
other subject matter
experts um and represent representative
Edwards States in an email he says the
legislature should invite key players
and stakeholders to share their facts
and assumptions such that an informed
decision may be made about whether any
intervention in the market around the
fiber infrastructure plan is
appropriate so that's about the extent
of my knowledge on the bill I am a
co-sponsor but I'm not privy to the the
conversations that representative
Edwards
had so uh happy to take any questions
and I'll do my best okay thank you
representative do we have any questions
for representative Ammon
representative Wendy
Thomas thank you I finally get to ask a
question um you said that this uh commit
committee not commission committee would
uh be in consultation with the
Pu why wasn't it turned into a
commission with them being a member of
this I don't know the answer to that
okay but a committee is just among the
legislature so right if you notice it
was very thoughtful of Representative
Edwards to include bipartisanship in the
committee so you'll notice that it's
members of each Party House and Senate
followup follow up um and also you
testified that this bill came about
because of a disgruntled employee that
you I did not use the word disgruntled
just the correct yeah a what well you
you used whistleblower in in quotes and
then you talked about an employee that
was not happy maybe I interpreted it as
disgruntled who was not happy because
they said that it was going to go too
slow or something like that I believe
it's it's going to go too quickly that
maybe there are
uh the way I understand it that that
there may be Market forces this is a
highly regulated market right there may
be uh incentives that are misaligned and
the the the concern is that it might
cause outages or cost overruns
particularly in rural areas we know
we're all trying to get Broadband to the
rural areas but just to clarify so this
bill came about because of one employee
correct and then excuse me
representative Thomas remember you have
to get permission from the chair to ask
followup questions I know but he started
talking before I could finish my
question okay maybe if you asked good
concise questions and he would be able
to answer them
succinctly go ahead I'm not asking
questions
representative Harrington has a question
okay thank you uh would it be best to
keep questions for somebody else on the
technical aspects of the bill like I
said I do my best if you if you want to
ask me a question but I I gave you the
pretty much the extent of my knowledge
on this legislation that on wait thank
you yeah we do have one more person who
has signed up to testify and she is
knowledgeable about this industry so she
may be able to provide more
information representative Kaplan did
you have a question
yeah okay thank you Mr chair I guess
I'll go ahead and ask my question and
hopefully representative Ammon can can
answer it I not sure maybe might be too
technical but um given that these are
internet service providers under the the
the regulatory domain of the Pu
correct yeah that's right so wouldn't an
issue like this be already under the
regulatory framework of a docket say it
may not be on anyone's radar at this
point I think this like I said this is
an exercise at sunlight that's the way I
understand it
so representative Harrington yeah just
just a comment these the uh pu does not
regulate internet they're regulated by
the FCC the state or no no state agency
or does any does the Pu regulate them at
all okay correct
then representativ bares has a
question thank you chairman and thank
you observative Amon for taking my
question um is you said that this is a
sunlight Bill does that mean that the
people you mentioned that are unnamed
will come and testify or How would how
would the details come about if uh the
Pu doesn't know these details and nobody
else knows these details so I I don't I
doubt that an individual will come and
testify uh but I think the idea is to
have the isps just present their plans
and just just so that we have some uh
you know oversight insight into what
they're planning to make sure that it's
not going to lead to outages I think
that's the
idea so the the information will come
from the
isps that's you know
hypothetically followup have you heard
anything from isbs saying that there are
issues representative brunsky I uh I
gave you pretty much all the information
I have on this bill so what so
representative Edwards he attended I
think I can divulge this a black tie
event yesterday in DC and he wasn't able
to make it back home in time so maybe
when he gets
back okay thank you I appreciate you
testifying for representative Edwards
now let's hear from M
Teresa representative
Corman one more question thank you for
taking my late uh for recognizing me for
my late question and thank you
representative adman for taking my
question I'm I'm trying to understand
what the outcome of this might be it's
uh it says that there might be
legislation so do you have any idea what
sort of legislation we'd be looking at
would it be something that would say
that the Pu can get involved
here potentially I mean it would be up
to the commission to decide if anything
is appropriate at all right but um
depending on what's uncovered that's
that would inform the the commission to
recommend
legislation okay thank you very much
represent pres ative let's now hear from
Teresa
Rosenberger uh representing
nhta good afternoon nice to see you
again nice to see all of you and this
new bium and uh I'm Teresa Rosenberger I
work for Bernstein Shore uh a law firm
in Manchester and I'm here representing
the Hampshire telephone Association and
Consolidated Communications that means
I'm representing all the landline old
mobile telephone companies I'm not
representing cable or Wireless I'm just
the old mobile telephone companies we
are neutral on this bill but frankly we
don't really think it's necessar
necessary the way the framework is set
up now all the companies I represent
already have their plans for buildout
their goal is
100% And um they all have plans and they
working towards those plans they have
engineering for this year engineering
started for next year uh Etc they're all
fairly close to 100% now but they are
continuing the bill some of the
companies have received Federal money
and if you've received Federal money in
one pot or another you have to let the
feds just as those who received arpa
money let New Hampshire's Department of
Business and economic development know
your addresses and where you're going so
there is that reporting requirement now
to the to the FCC and represent of
Harrington's
correct it's it's the FCC that's the
jurisdictional body um and and the FCC
puts out a plan as when it has to be
completed as did the New Hampshire uh
Bea put out a plan um also the current
rules are if you are going to do any
discontinuance of cop
um you have to notify you have to make
an application first to the FCC and then
you have to
notify uh or we notify the FCC the Pu
and the governor's office when you're
making that application to discontinu um
copper uh the other comment I have is
when we looked at the bill it's really
only referring to Copper however that's
in the first paragraph in the duties it
doesn't refer to Copper um um we there
are other ISP carriers who have used old
technologies that are not copper so
we're asking why you're making it
technology specific to only one segment
of the
industry um the other issue we have is
that that if just this segment has to
tell you where you're going it gives a
real competitive advantage to the other
parts of the industry because they know
where you're going they know what your
plans are and you don't know what theirs
are so you can't figure out what's the
best place to um to spend your your your
Capital dollars and other than that some
of the information when they're spending
their own money is
proprietory so basically bottom line is
everybody's moving I'm surprised
somebody would say it's going too fast
because most people say it's going too
slow but um everybody all of my clients
have a plan working through their plan
and their goal is 100% copper one client
for example that has Federal money
literally has targets of 50% by this
year 75 by that
year 100 by the other other clients that
have New Hampshire AR Perani absolutely
have a
deadline so I'd be happy to answer any
questions and um from there it looks
like I have a
few okay questions for Miss Ro wenberg
Michael Harrington representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I guess I
just wanted to clarify one point if you
help me here uh you had said that the
FCC is the governing body here so I see
this part that says any recommendations
for proposed legislation to the best of
your knowledge would the state of New
Hampshire have any authority to impose
legislation on the uh the industry the
cable industry that's regulated by the
Federal Communication Commission thank
thank you for the question
representative Harrington I do not think
so uh the cable industry the isps nor
the traditional mbell companies are
regulated by the Pu that de the
deregulation went in effect I think
2012 thank
you representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um just a
point of clarification you testified
that um there are other old technologies
that are not copper can you just
identify those first please uh I think
Mrs West is here from the the cable
Association but I think Co coax I think
the cable uses coax whereas the
landlines use copper and I'm not sure
besides that but people the
industry was and has been in continues
to be technology in some ways agnostic I
mean there are things out there now that
you're going to see that aren't fiber
and so um that was why it was peculiar
to me that in the the EST establishment
it was talking about copper but it
didn't in the duties talk talk about
copper so I I'm not sure where they
wanted to go or who who this person is
that complain and what industry which
part of the industry it is thank you
you're
welcome representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question um be being that I work in the
networking field myself I won't make it
too technical so I'm try to um forgive
me if I do but uh with cost overruns as
as was noted by the uh person the sub um
person that actually submitted this um
the FC with the FCC regulations as well
the bulk of the overruns now we know
fiber optic cable itself there's not
much difference between what size it is
oc3 oc2 and that but the O cost actually
comes in the switching and the
transceivers of the re repeating and the
uh the repeating and the length of the
fiber con connectivity
um and these would be owned by the
service providers so again to go off of
what representative Harrington said I
know it falls under FCC but would the
state would not have any regulation over
what equipment switching and
transceivers that these companies use
correct that is
correct representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you m Rosenberger for coming in this
might be beating a dead horse but I I
think it would be Dar like not to ask it
considering what the the testimony of
the sponsor who came came in and said
that there might be electrical outages
based on these cost overruns or based on
the market dynamics that are at play
here in this transition so are you aware
at all of anything that would impact on
electrical service in this transition
impact on on the on the electrical
service being provided by any electrical
service electrical yeah gosh you're over
my head no I'm not I'm not I'm not aware
of any cost of runs that would be
impacting the electricals service no no
I'm sorry
no okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you for being here thank
you very much and since I have no more
pink cards on this um for this hearing
I'm going to close this public
hearing and I'm going to allow members a
five minute break before we start our
next public hearing so everyone please
be back here by 2:15
and we'll start the next public hearing
at 2:15 thank
you thanks for
no
no you have to off the bill
my phes
you see
I e
this
I
think e
around
little e
you e
just e
please take your seats
okay I'm going to open a public hearing
on House Bill
526 FN establishing a client climate
change and damage division in the
Department of Environmental Services and
I'm going to call on representative
Wendy Thomas to introduce this
legislation oh hey it's me for the
record I am Wendy Thomas and I represent
the town of marac I'm here to introduce
House Bill 526
which seeks to establish the division of
climate change and damage within the
Department of Environmental Services
this division is not just a necessary
step toward addressing the growing and
Urgent issue of climate change but it is
also a Strategic investment in the
future of New
Hampshire first and foremost the
division will focus on climate
adaptation planning identifying
vulnerabilities such as sea level rise
extreme weather events and shifting
ecosystems
from recent testimony we have heard
about cases of this already happening
with the flooding of our Sea Coast the
warming of our Winters the higher
precipitation in the summer increased
cyanobacteria blooms in warmer bodies of
water and we have even heard from the
hydropower folks that our fish
population is changing Mount Washington
is doing a lot of climate work as is the
UNH Cooperative what we need is a
repository to gather all of this
information by conducting assessments
and developing resilience plans the
state will be better prepared to protect
its communities infrastructure and
natural resources with the increasing
frequency and severity of climate
related events this proactive approach
is crucial for safeguarding New
Hampshire New Hampshire's
future the creation of this division
also ensures that climate action in our
state is rooted in sound science and
data through research and climate
modeling New Hampshire will have the
tools to forecast potential climate uh
potential future climate conditions and
develop informed effective policies the
regular monitoring and reporting of
climate change impacts will help ensure
that the state remains responsive to the
changing conditions providing valuable
information to both government agencies
and the public equally important is the
division's focus on public engagement
and education by Leading awareness
campaigns and collabor collaborating
with local communities businesses and
organizations the division will Empower
citizens to take sustainable actions and
work together toward common climate
goals this approach Fosters a culture of
cooperation and ensures that New
Hampshire's response to climate change
is inclusive and community-driven
finally the division will play a crucial
role in funding and grants management
allocating resources to support climate
change mitigation and adaptation
efforts excuse me by administering
incentive programs and supporting local
incentives this division will provide
the necessary tools and funding to
encourage sustainable practices and help
businesses and individuals contribute to
climate action this bill is not only
about addressing the the challenges of
climate change it's about seizing the
opportunity to position New Hampshire as
a leader
in climate resilience and
sustainability by creating a division
dedicated to this issue we are ensuring
that our state remains adaptable
responsive and proactive in the face of
one of our most pressing issues of our
time thank you and I'll take any
questions thank you representative
Thomas for introducing House Bill
526 I have a couple of questions for you
sure on Page One MH line
five and six it says that the director
of climate change shall be nominated by
the commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services from a list of
three
candidates where does the list of
candidates come
from and why
three uh that is actually wording that
was put in there by the OS loyer and
that was not in the original text do you
remember what your original intent was
uh just that someone would be nominated
and and it it didn't have to be from a
list of three
people okay second question if you go
down to uh or go back up to line four it
says
that the division of climate change and
damage would be under the supervision of
an
unclassified director of climate change
and damage would that not indicate that
the department would be responsible for
hiring
someone and if that is the case wouldn't
it be incumbent upon this legislation to
appropriate funds to the department to
do just that the legislation however
does not appropriate any funds and the
finance committee has told us not to
send them any leg legislation that
requires the expenditure of funds that
are not appropriated well thank you for
the question um in order to well from
what I understand there are some people
within uh Dees that that are uh
dedicated to climate already there there
used to be a fellow um and I forget the
I forget the position but um he had
climate in his title as far as as hiring
somebody I would think
that this probably would result in the
hiring of at least one employee um I am
as disappointed as you are at the fiscal
note that basically says nobody picked
up the phone so we can't uh establish
any kind of a uh a price for
this and I understand that the the the
finance committee has said don't send us
any bills that that require um any
expenses to me that's not exactly fair
to the people of New Hampshire because
if we have a bill that is very important
and that would help the people of New
Hampshire to say WR out that we
shouldn't even consider it I think is
irresponsible well what the finance
committee has said is don't send us
money that have uh don't send us bills
that have the expenditure of money
without the appropriation of money so
it's okay to spend money as long as you
designate that there is an appropriation
made uh for some amount uh and but this
what I'm saying is that this this legisl
has written does not appropriate any
funds
whatsoever okay so are there other
questions representative Harrington has
one thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just to follow up on
that idea uh you it specifies having a
director of climate change and damage
it's hard for me to conceive that we're
going to establish a new division in
Dees with just a director and no one
that works for them it's going to be a
single person so I I would assume if
this would have passed we're looking at
you know three four five new new people
uh could be one could be just you're
saying we're going to have a director
with nobody that works for him in charge
of a division of one person no I'm
saying a a director um although I mean a
director could be a a committee I mean
depending how much they do but um at
least one employee under the director is
is I
think reasonable all right thank
you okay additional questions
seeing none thank you representative
Thomas for introducing this legislation
next I'd like to hear from Mike
Fitzgerald from the Department of
Environmental Services to get their
perspective on this
legislation welcome Mr Fitzgerald nice
to see
you thank you very much appreciate that
uh Mike Fitzgerald Department of
Environmental Services assistant
director the air Resources Division uh
currently responsible for uh the work
that we're doing in climate uh I do want
to correct one misconception that uh we
did the assistant commissioner did sign
a fiscal note and it was sent down last
week uh he signed it on the 7th I don't
know exactly when it went down it's
unfortunate that it was uh uh not
reflected here but I wrote the note so
um I'm happy to answer questions on it
and uh I I will summarize by saying that
as was so so surmised we assumed that
this would require an additional at
least one additional position um there
are a number of activities that are
noted here that um we're already uh
undertaking uh and specifically section
one um paragraph one beginning on uh uh
line 11 the adaptation planning work a
lot of that work is already being done
with the SE Coast hazards risk uh
commission and um working with a number
of Upper Valley has an adaptation work
group um so uh and we are also uh
utilizing uh our federal SE climate
pollution reduction grant that I uh uh
showed spoke to you about last week when
we presented to you um and I have three
staff working on that Grant
currently uh my concern is uh that that
Grant will will last maybe for another
two years um and uh
um the uh work that's required here is
is ongoing so uh as uh you you and
representative Thomas recognized um the
we would need a a director uh I'm not
sure if that title just means director
of climate change but it's a staff level
if it's a director it would be unusual
that it be um that there'd be no staff
um under it uh and direct and a director
is an appointed position um typically
and so um and the work that's noted in
paragraph two here is extremely highly
Technical and complex in nature um
research and data analysis conducting
climate modeling and scenario planning
Etc so we estimated that this would
probably take an additional two or three
staff um uh and again some some of this
you know is is work that's already being
done so we you know could assimilate
some of it but U uh certainly the fiscal
note did indicate that we felt we would
need additional staff that was not
authorized by the
bill so with that I'd be happy to take
any
questions could
you define for us or describe for us the
difference between an
unclassified position within state
government and a classified position
well classified I believe is subject to
the Personnel Personnel rules and is is
hired through the state system
unclassified would be for instance I'm
classified um I'm an assistant director
the director of the division is
nominated by the governor and approved
by the council um and those are
unclassified
positions okay so it's a position that
requires approval by the governor and
the executive Council nomination by the
governor and approval of the council
okay all right thank you for that I
think the wording that's in here is is
pro probably was intended to reflect
that but I think it just came came out
wrong but it's it's uh I think they're
working on a thousand bills over there
so I I'll give them some
slack okay representative Summers has a
question for you thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh this
actually just ties to a bunch of things
that just happened recently and I'm I
kind of concerned or question about some
of the items and especially when it
comes to the uh the change and damage
part and uh with the um the T testimony
of the of the um EPA the person's
running for the Secretary of EPA as well
as the Secretary of United Nations has
stated that the uh that there's a and
with the um executive order signed
Yesterday by President Trump for all
above approach uh how would the um the
fact of doing this with a change and
damage coincide with with climate change
and with the damage caused by fossil
fuels how would it coincide with the
with them stating that there's an all
above approach for the uh for the
government well I think we take our
direction from the governor so we would
uh uh it would you know we're an
executive branch agency within the state
of New Hampshire U the federal uh
approach if you're talking about EPA
funds and funding um which as I said we
do have a cprg grant if they change
direction on that Grant policy we would
we would follow that the only work that
we are doing on climate mitigation not
adaptation but climate mitigation is uh
related to developing a climate plan uh
as I mentioned in the presentation I
gave you last week um and and so if the
administration were to change direction
on that we would follow whatever ever
policies were given to us with regards
to a state of New Hampshire position
under state government that would be at
the direction of the governor and the
commissioner of the
agency representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking this very simple question
usually when we have an agency come here
for a bill such as this we get a support
opposer neutral I haven't heard anything
from Dees neutral
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Fitzgerald um the
section you didn't mention was section
three on line 25 where it says public
engagement in education including
leading awareness campaigns to educate
citizens and working with local
communities to develop initiatives that
address uh climate change at the local
level what I wanted to ask you about
that is um myself and chairman Vose were
members for about four years on the easy
board which is since has been dissolved
and we were in the process of procuring
uh a public awareness campaign around
Energy Efficiency and some other aspects
of lowering emissions um and that got
moved over to the Department of energy
and I think part of the uh part of this
bill and some other efforts I have seen
are to figure out where does the buck
stop and where does how do the agencies
of government cover
uh this piece in terms of support for
the public so we know that the
Department of Environmental Services is
responsible for the pollution piece and
you also are responsible for tracking
the regional greenhouse gas init
initiative numbers and money coming into
the state uh from that
program but is there some confusion
around I I I think this bill is trying
to clarify where uh ownership would lie
for anything Rel related to um climate
damages and costs coming into the into
the state so is there any
um I don't I don't know what the right
word would be is there any lack of
clarity around who owns this
piece is it straddling two agencies
because I know that you used to have
someone who had climate in their title
um Chris scogland when I first came into
the legislature he was the person that
would come into this room and talk to us
about those programs so is has anyone
taken over his role in your agency maybe
that's a better way to answer it the
position that was currently that was
previously held by Mr scogland is
currently staffed by someone working
under the climate pollution reduction
Grant um we we shifted the funding on
that okay um and uh our work on Reggie
is is funded by Reggie um that comes
comes from the administration portion of
that with regard to Clarity or not un
Clarity um currently there are no State
statutes that address climate change um
and so we have no other than the fact
that we accepted a Federal grant which
we consulted with the governor's office
on previously um we uh and that was to
enable us as you I mentioned last week
that was to enable us to be able to
apply for $4.5 billion dollar in federal
funding um of which we did receive a
$450 million five state
Grant we for the heat pump accelerator
program um but uh other than that there
is no State funding and no State
authorization to address climate change
um and we're doing all all the work that
we're doing on climate is currently
being done under the opes of that
funding and we're doing a a a climate
plan and a number of the things that are
addressed in section three um are being
done stakeholder Outreach education we
working with the University of New
Hampshire Etc but all under the opes of
that um that Federal grant so followup
followup so I guess then the last
question would be if if this bill or an
amended version to this bill were to
pass would you be able to reconstitute
your existing resources in order to meet
the requirements of of having someone
who's playing point on this or would it
still require and additional people to
be
added well again uh we I I have four
staff that are currently working on cprg
grant that are they're doing some of
this we have some staff in our Water
Division who are working on the
adaptation side of this and so on so we
would need to sit down do an
assessment making make a determination
of what we think the bill directed us to
do obviously work with the governor's
office relative to to Staffing and and
budget uh constraints and uh but I'm I
would say of of all of the items that
are in this bill the area that concerns
me is section two um regarding the
research and Analysis so on that would
require a couple of one or two certainly
one or two new positions or some
repurposing of the federal positions but
again when that Federal money goes away
there would need to be State money to to
uh authorize that and State State you
know I mean this this bill would need to
pass so representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr fit for coming in um I and I want
to express my appreciation for the work
that you're doing on the climate action
plan and uh in terms of resilience work
with the different uh Regional
development um bodies so um
understanding that all of this is in
play in terms of the politics involved
uh the in in terms of the funding that's
available uh but irregardless of that if
this bill were to pass it's just on a
theoretical conceptual level would you
do you see a benefit to the work that is
being done in terms of resilience in
terms of education and taking taking
away the research piece and the analysis
piece because I do recognize that that
might not be in your in your Bailey Wick
so to speak um do you see a benefit to
this bill in terms of furthering the
work that is being
done yes we certainly believe it is an
area that there's
um uh education and and uh uh providing
um some some leadership um again that
would be at the direction
of the legislature if this bill were to
pass and um under the implementation of
the governor but
yes all right thank you seeing no
further questions I want to thank Mr
fritzgerald
you got to raise your hand faster than
that representative partial has a
question thank you chair and thank you
for coming today I appreciate your time
here thank you um is it possible to uh
have your the fiscal note we submitted
to the OSS shared with the committee it
to my best of my knowledge it has been
submitted to Ls I'm not sure when this
was printed and and so on and it they
they may have crossed paths but um it
was signed by our assistant commissioner
on the 7th of
January check the calendar
representative partial because I recall
seeing one of those boxes that they put
in the calendar that notifies us when
new fiscal notes are available and I
think it gives us a way to access those
physical notes I'll take a look there
thank you very much for that information
check that out thank you all right thank
you Mr Fitzgerald next up we'll hear
from Nick Koff of the conservation law
Foundation
good afternoon I'm Nick coff senior
attorney with the conservation law
Foundation um thanks again for having me
here today really appreciate it um you
know I was here last week and I talked a
lot about the um climate change and sort
of the defects we're realizing from
climate change over the past several
decades um you know climate change is
and will continue to affect the state's
economy its infrastructure and its
ecosystems and um the committee should
really pass this bill in order to
establish a division within Dees um to
further study the issue to study the
impacts to the state and to um plan on
how to adapt to the to the issue um you
know as I talked about last week we're
seeing shorter and warmer Winters in the
state this is affecting um winter
Recreation Industries throughout the
state um we're experiencing rising sea
levels
um in the in since the beginning of the
um 20th century sea levels have Ren 8
Ines already and are expected to rise
even further over the coming decades um
and this is affecting properties and the
Sea Coast Area um you know really
affecting people's livelihoods there and
businesses in the Sea Coast um as it's
um exacerbating extreme weather in that
area
um you know we're also
seeing uh pretty significant effects for
our Wildlife um with the moose
population it's worsening um you know
with the winter tick situation which is
really decimating our moose population
in the state and you know just going out
the woods these days you really have to
worry about ticks this wasn't a thing 30
years ago but you know going for a hike
nowadays it's it's a real issue um so
consolidating all of de's activities
into a single division that can um
further study the issue and figure out
how to better adapt to climate change is
really needed um right now um you know
given the effects that are happening in
the state and you know for those reasons
I think uh you should vote a to pass on
this bill and happy to take your
questions I've um submitted written
testimony that provide more detail as
well okay thank you representative
Summers has a question thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh to uh last week's testimony
especially with the EPA this came from
the Senate environmental um Senate board
federally where it stated that Western
Europe and the United States create or
produce about 15% of the uh CO2 within
the within the world environment uh with
remaining especially in Asia Asia and
developing countries developed 85% so
even if the United States completely New
Hampshire went to zero United States
went to completely zero would this have
a small effect compared to 85% of the
rest of the pollution being caused
supposed pollution caused by the rest of
the world outside the US well um this
bill is thanks thank you for the
question but this bill is all about
climate change adaptation and not
mitigation so it's not seeking to solve
the issue of climate change it's seeing
to figure out how we adapt to that issue
so regardless of who's causing climate
change um you know which which countries
are more um contributing more to the
issue this is really trying to figure
out how does the State adapt to the
changes that we're seeing so you know
what do we do to respond to rising sea
levels What do we do to um you know
protect our moose population it's not
really seeking to you know reverse that
Trend or or stop the trend of climate
change followup so I guess I'm asking is
H is it the financial responsibility of
the West to spend it spend into Infinity
the amount of money to Halt climate
change when 85% of the environments
caused by outside of the
West I mean that's a very valid question
um but you know I think if you look at
the overall levels of CO2 um in the
atmosphere basically starting from the
Industrial Revolution when we started um
you know emitting CO2 into the air you
know Western countries have been
responsible for a large portion of that
amount so regardless of who's you know
emitting more CO2 now um You the the
overall level um Western countries have
been you know responsible but you know I
I think regardless of that you know I'm
not saying that we need to spend
infinite an infinite amount um I think
the better way to look at it is you know
we need to start planning you know a how
to reduce the effects of climate change
if we can and be how to adapt to those
those um you know those impacts and
basically the sooner we start thinking
about that you know the less money we're
going to have to spend and the longer we
weight um you know the more financial
cost it'll be
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman and yeah to bring
the um questioning and Responding back
to what this bill is actually about we
heard a lot last week in our briefings
about the to me very surprising number
of
dams on our waterways throughout the
state some of which are involved in
producing hydrop power but many many of
which just
provide you know Environmental Services
flood control and frankly a lot of
economic uh benefit in terms of
shorelines that host high value homes
uh the uh that increasing
um frequency of you know High
precipitation events is one of those
significant climate impacts that we're
seeing and wouldn't this position in
Dees gathering information and forecasts
and talk and providing information about
that effect isn't that one of the things
that uh one of the benefits that this
position in Dees would have yeah
absolutely I mean I um you know if you
look at Summer of 2023 there was a you
know some big storms in the Upper Valley
and you know there there was a dam or
two that got washed out that summer and
um yeah one of the goals of this bill or
objectives of this bill would be to you
know look at you know how climate change
is affecting infrastructure and how do
we adapt to that you know do we need to
make upgrades infrastructure do we need
to you know make certain changes so that
you know that that infrastructure is is
climate proofed
essentially okay further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you for your testimony and since that
finishes up the folks who want to
testify on House Bill 526 I'm going to
close that public hearing next we'll
open up a public hearing on House Bill
dfn and I'll call on representative
Thomas Corman to introduce this
legislation to us
before you get started Tom
representative
PL um at the conclusion of this public
hearing before we go to exec session I
want you to read the results of the the
contents of the blue sheets on all the
bills we've heard this afternoon thank
you representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman for the record Tom Corman I
represent Grafton 15 which is Ward three
of the fair city of
Lebanon uh I have introduced an
amendment uh as chair Vose informed us
last week the prime sponsor of a bill
May introduce an amendment at the
hearing so I'm I have introduced an
amendment uh members all have it it is
number
2025-the which I hope the amendment
makes very clear is that any action
taken by the public utilities
commissioner should require the support
of at least two of the three
Commissioners a little
background RSA 363 which is about the Pu
uh 363 colon one says and I am going to
quote the chair of the commission shall
have the powers and duties set forth in
RSA 21g colon n unquote so these powers
in that RSA are intended for the
commissioners of
departments and if you look at RSA 21 G9
it says the commissioner shall be the
chief administrative officer of the
department and shall have the following
powers and duties and listed among those
powers and duties in par in uh section n
paragraph 2B it says adopt all rules of
the department whether the rule making
Authority delegated by the legislature
is granted to the commissioner the
department or any administrative unit or
subordinate official of the department
unquote so this language that's in
statute gives the Pu chair the power to
set all the rules independent of what
the other two Commissioners
think I don't know whether this is what
the legisl intended but it means that
the other two Commissioners may be
ignored by the Pu chair at least that's
the way I read it I don't think that's
really what the legislature intended and
what we wanted so the bill that I have
submitted simply says that any action
taken by the Pu must be agreed to by at
least two of the Commissioners and the
amendment makes that crystal clear it
says uh two Commissioners shall
constitute a quorum to hold a hearing
and issue orders or establish rules or
both uh actually oh it's different wait
a minute this is different from what I
had here um it says two Commissioners
shall constitute a quorum regardless of
any vacancies this changed from uh my
com my uh communication with OS a quorum
is required for the commission to
conduct any authorized proceeding or
take any actions so the point is it
makes it clear that you need two
Commissioners to actually agree on an
action by the Pu the chair alone is not
sufficient so if there is a vacancy on
the Pu and this is what the fiscal note
of the bill got to if there's a vacancy
on the Pu then the two remaining
Commissioners would need to agree if
there were two vacancies on the Pu then
no action should be taken by the
commission um until at least there's one
new commissioner appointed by the
governor and the executive Council and
that's really the way it should be I
mean if there's just one person left
that's not a commission that's one
person so I don't even think there was a
need for fiscal note on this bill I
don't think any special commissioner on
retainer is needed and I actually think
the bill as introduced was misunderstood
because in the original bill it talked
about at least 2third of the commission
regardless of any
vacancies
now I think I know a little bit about
mathematics I'm the lead author of a
very technical textbook on computer
algorithms and when I think of what at
least two 23 of three means that means
at least two so they there doesn't need
to be a commissioner on retainer to fill
out a third position two should suffice
so I I don't think there even needs to
be a fiscal note here if the commission
is down by one person the two remaining
need to agree if the commission is down
by two people there has to be at least
one more person appointed if the
commission is down three people WOTE to
us so uh with that um I will take any
questions thank you for introducing this
legislation and this
amendment so let's assume
that two pu Commissioners resign health
reasons moving out of state whatever so
there's only one commissioner
left the governor needs to nominate two
new Commissioners and then they have to
be appr vetted and approved by the
executive councel both of those things
could take
months does that mean if your bill
passed would that mean that the Pu would
essentially its activity would grind to
a halt until those two new Commissioners
were appointed and the executive Council
approved
them since the the commission would not
have a quorum and could not conduct any
business
and if that's the case what would happen
to the other 13 14 employees of the
commission would they be furl would
they just sit around and twiddle their
thumbs what what would happen describe
to us under that scenario what would
happen well I would imagine and I'm I'm
certainly not um an expert on how the Pu
operates internally I would imagine
there's still plenty of work that gets
done internally uh within the the Pu
regardless of of how many Commissioners
are there but the main thing is it is
incumbent upon the governor and the
council to to do that job to actually
get somebody on there and if the
governor drags their feet or if the
council drags their feet then uh in in
the scenario where there's zero or one
commissioner the state's suffering and
that means that the governor and councel
are not getting their job
done well my follow-up question would
be it's not only the Pu that would
suffer but all the states rate payers
would suffer the state's utilities would
suffer it seems to me that work would
would grind to a total halt under that
scenario and that would not be a good
thing for our state is that not the case
uh Mr chairman I actually agree with you
entirely it would be terrible for the
work to grind to a halt uh that's why
they need to actually make sure that it
is staffed and as soon as one
commissioner is gone resigns or whatever
they need to actually work on getting
another one but more to the point a
commissioner does not make a commission
the commission is
statutorily uh composed of three
Commissioners and one commissioner is
not a
commission okay additional question
questions for the representative
representative
Swanson it isn't spelled out in here but
is
it would it be practical to have say an
interim or system or process wherein
there would be an interim appointment
until there could actually be a physical
action on the part of the governor
governor uh given how long you know
bureaucracy takes to make things happen
sometimes when a vacancy occurs
unexpectedly I don't know the answer to
that and I don't know if um anyone from
the puc is going to
testify um I would imagine that the
amount of of background needed to be on
the
Pu could make it a little difficult
perhaps there could be somebody who had
been on the Pu stepping in
um and in terms of
that uh the fiscal note there if that
person were in fact drawing some sort of
compensation well there's compensation
not going to the to the person who's not
there so again I don't see that it would
be a big um fiscal
problem uh I'm not suggesting anybody be
on retainer and I don't know if you are
but you know I just think that perhaps
somebody could step in uh temporarily
but somebody you know who's been on on
the commission before thank you Mr chair
thank you representative Corman
further
questions representative rolds thank you
Mr chairman thank you Tom for being here
I mean in just briefly would you
characterize your bill uh
clarifying that there needs to be at
least two at least a majority of a
commission uh to exist at all times uh
to take action would would you
characterize it as a good government
bill I mean in bodies that are
constituted in uh odd numbers three five
like Boards of Selectmen and City
councils uh that regularly hold votes
where it takes a a majority to make a
decision uh you're just clarifying
aren't you just clarifying that there
needs to be enough
members to hold a vote
that that's part of it but also
clarifying that uh the way that RSA 363
colon one says that the chair of the
commission has the powers and duties set
forth in RSA 21g col 9 and that that
actually gives the chair of the Pu the
powers that a a commissioner of a
department has and I don't think that's
really what we intend
so is your real
objection the fact
that as currently worded state law in uh
g9b allows a single commissioner to
adopt rules is that the the Crux of the
issue here even though jel car has to
approve those rules and if the
commissioner adopted rules that gel car
and its
process didn't think were
acceptable those rules wouldn't go
forward yeah I still think that there
should be at least two Commissioners on
the Pu this is why we have the Pu it's
three it should be three people and
there should be at least two who adopt a
rule representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um you may
not have the ansers to this question but
I'm intrigued by the fiscal note that
says that a um a special commissioner
would start at 1
15,850 do you know is that the starting
salary for a
commissioner that I do not know thank
you other questions representative
Harrington yeah I'm still a little
confused about what this is trying to
accomplish U looking at the bill before
it was change your your bill here with
the if you take out the what was changed
it says the commission shall any
majority of the commission which is we
know is since it's three it's two
constitutes a quorum to issue orders and
any hearing may be held or conducted by
two Commissioners or by a single
commissioner so I guess what you're
saying that that was lined out so you're
saying in this chapter majority means at
least 2third of the commission
regardless of any
vacancies so what you're trying to
clarify there that is if there was only
two Commissioners because one resigned
that you'd you you'd have to have 2third
of the full commissioner meeting two at
all times is the minimum amount correct
that was my intention and and I think it
was not interpreted in that way in the
fiscal note okay
followup yes but so what this is saying
you could have one commissioner would be
for a hearing but they couldn't issue
any
orders and there's also the uh provision
in the law La that anybody that wants a
no hearing except in accident cases
shall be held or conducted by a single
commissioner if any party whose interest
may be affected shall five days before
the date request in writing the be
commission to be conducted by a full
commissioner or a majority thereof so if
there was a hearing and somebody even
even the hearing now they can't issue
orders that's already established but if
there was a hearing and someone was
involved in that hearing they could say
uh I don't want one commissioner I want
at least two and they would have to get
at least two that's the present
law um well I think the present law says
that a hearing can be conducted by a
single commissioner right that's that's
that's that's the part that that we
would be St St stricken out a followup
if you go to
3627 it talks about requests for a full
commission it's a it's a separate
section and in there it says no hearing
except in accident cases they be held or
conducted by a single commissioner if
any party whose interest may be affected
shall 5 days prior to the date of the
hearing request in writing that the same
be held to conducted by the full
commission or a majority thereof so
anybody that wants to could say one
commission is not good enough you you
don't you don't think that protects
people enough and this is just for a
hearing now they still couldn't you
couldn't issue an order with one right
right but yeah I mean I I'm I'm I'm not
sure
exactly what you're asking I'll I'll
just say this I I think that a hearing
should have two Commissioners because if
a decision requires two Commissioners at
least one of the people making this
decision should have been at the
hearing okay well I'm not quite
following you okay anyways thank
additional
questions seeing none thank you
representative for introducing this
legislation now let's hear from the
consumer Advocate Donald C to get his
perspective on this legislation
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to be
brief uh just as I was earlier I'm
Donald Cree the consumer Advocate my job
is to represent the interests of
residential utility customers but right
now I'm going to put on my
administrative law professor hat I used
to teach administrative law before I
became consumer Advocate during my long
and checkered career for a few years
so there are two things that a
regulatory agency does whether it's the
Federal Communications Commission the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission or
the New Hampshire Public Utilities
Commission they make decisions two ways
one is through
adjudication that applies when there are
the rights and privileges a particular
singular party at issue or the agency
adopts rules and those are decisions
that apply across the board to everybody
and so it doesn't make any sense as a
matter of I guess you could say
political science uh to constitute
something like the Public Utilities
Commission and say Well when it
adjudicates things it's going to do that
as a tribunal of three Commissioners but
when it exercises its rulemaking
Authority there really isn't a pu
anymore there is a chairman of the Pu
and all of the authority reposes in the
chair of the Pu now the reason that the
the chair of the Pu has all of the rule
making Authority has already been
established when the department of
energy was created via the Budget
Trailer bill in 2021 inserted into the
Budget Trailer bill was an amendment to
RSA 363 Section 1 that says and I quote
the chair of the commission shall have
the powers and duties set forth in RSA
G9 now I do not think and I was around
to watch all of this happen that the
legislature intended when it created the
department of energy via the Budget
Trailer Bill uh four years ago to divest
the puc the three commissioners of their
rul making Authority and transfer it to
the chair of the puc the person who
inserted that language in the Budget
Trailer bill I think knew exactly what
she was doing but I don't think the
legislature understood that and so so
therefore I think the purpose of this
bill that you are now hearing is to fix
that and restore it to the full three
member pu the authority to promulgate
rules it's a little perplexing from my
perspective how the clarity of that
purpose and the relative ease with which
that problem could be solved has somehow
gotten all muddled here I mean if it was
up to me I would just change the
language in RSA
3631 to say something something like the
chair of the commission shall have the
powers and duties set forth in RSA 21 G9
except for the power to promulgate rules
which shall Repose in the commission
meaning the three Commissioners that I
think is a pretty straightforward and
simple way of getting to achieving the
purpose of this bill without getting all
wound up about uh how many Commissioners
you need to hold a hearing or how many
Commissioners you need to make a
decision and when you need and when you
don't need to uh appoint special
Commissioners because uh as you've
already established that question is
fraught there is already a statute that
protects people's right to demand or
request a full commissioner all of that
so I I I really think this bill could be
drafted in a much more surgical way to
accomplish what I think it is trying to
accomplish and I don't think what it is
trying to accomplish is especially
controversial because I think the
legislature didn't realize for years ago
that it was divesting the full pu of its
ruem Authority okay that's probably more
than you need to hear from me about that
subject so I'll stop talking and then if
the chairman wants to have me answer any
questions I'd be delighted to do
that so this is what I wrote
down we could append to the end of that
full sentence in on line four the chair
of the the commission shall have the
powers and duties set forth in RSA 21
G9 except for the adoption of commission
rules which requires a majority of the
commission that would be perfect you did
an excellent job of drafting the
amendment that I would suggest you adopt
should I try to get a job at
OS I think you should apply for a job at
the OCA we need a new staff attorney
so okay questions for the consumer
advocate
representative McGee thank you I had a
question before you went ahead and did
that which I think would solve the
problem um the question that I had was
it it appears that when we do make these
references that we often don't follow
through to figure out whether it's going
to give us what we intend it it sounds
like RSA 21 G9 relates in general to the
commissioners of the other agencies not
to a regulatory body which the Pu is
distinct so that's why
um that reference then without the
exception doesn't give us uh the way the
Pu was constituted before this change
happened is that a correct
interpretation yes you know going back
to the warm summer of
2021 which was H uh unfolding while the
pandemic was still somewhat raging I
think the idea was that the Pu wanted to
eliminate the uh office of its executive
director and make clear that the chair a
person of the Pu is the administrative
head of the agency and I think that was
probably a reasonable thing to do I'm
not sure it's what I would have done but
it's not an unreasonable thing to do
I'll put it that way so the way to do
that apparently was to vest in the chair
all of the powers and duties set forth
in 21 G9 but one of those powers and
duties is Rule making so it's it's not
what I would have done it's logical it
created this problem which I think the
general court itself didn't realize it
was
creating additional
questions all right seeing none thank
you for your testimony and suggestion
thank you for the
opportunity we have one more fol one
more person to hear from and that is
Alex Sidell from the Public Utilities
Commission welcome
back thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
members of the committee
so uh the Public Utilities Commission on
the pink sheet registered its opposition
to this bill and I just wanted to
clarify that we are discussing the bills
proposed at the present time not
involving any amendments and so I'll be
keying off of the fiscal note discussion
and the language as proposed in the bill
and I'll read it because there is the
insertion on line three of the word
regulatory uh which in part one which is
intriguing I it may have something to do
with some of the discussions surrounding
our investigative authorities but we'll
leave that aside but looking at part
two the language reads Quorum 363 colon
16 a majority of the commission shall
constitute a quorum and then their
striketh through of this language to
issue orders and any hearing may be held
or conducted by two Commissioners or by
a single commissioner so that's being
stricken through in this proposed
legislation and then the insertion of in
this chapter majority quote unquote
means at least 2third of the commission
regardless of any vacancies so the
reasoning behind the fiscal note was
that there is a constant flow of
hearings work at the commission and
there is a constant flow of order
issuances happening at the commission so
12 months a year 300 65 days of of
working days a year it seems like it
sometimes um constant orders being
issued constant acceptances of petitions
hearings reviews so the flow of work is
constant and having interned at the New
Hampshire Supreme Court it's been 20
years amazing to to think about it but
that was 20 years ago um the Supreme
Court
interprets the language of a statute in
its totality and all the provisions have
to work together and when there's an
ambiguity the Supreme Court really digs
into the legislative record and looks at
what was proposed and why it was
proposed and how it was proposed so if
the legislature is striking through in
this proposed Bill two issue orders and
any hearing may be held or conducted by
two Commissioners or by a single
commission or that's an indication to
the Supreme Court that the legislator
means this to have only three Commission
hearings no matter what hence the
potential of the special
commissioner so why would the
Commissioners be absent well there's
vacancies due to resignation as uh
commissioner Simpson recently
resigned uh there's vacancies uh during
the working week due to illness or
accident there can also be many
responsibilities that the Commissioners
discharge outside of the form of the
commission itself so they have to go to
governor and Council meetings they often
appear here at the
legislature in one form or another and
time flies and sometimes they have to
give presentations on the spot and
furthermore they interface with their
colleagues around the country at the
national regulatory commissioner
Association meetings which are very
important and they also have Federal
side responsibilities uh we are the
junior partner of the dep Department of
energy in the field of wholesale
regulation as you heard from
commissioner chado patai
and there's also ongoing fora and
interactions related to uh National
Security
responsibilities in the field of
critical
infrastructure uh that the Commissioners
have to be involved in so their docket
is very full
they have to have all this done in a
given year in a given work week and so
sometimes you even if you have a full
roster of three Commissioners it's tough
to rustle up two Commissioners but it
can be done but if you must rustle
up three Commissioners for everything
for every issuance of an order for every
hearing it's going to be uh impossible
just stop the work of the commission and
as far as the single commissioner
Provisions is concerned I would urge
given the safeguards that uh former
commissioner and representative
Harrington referred to in
3637 that it be retained just in case of
emergency in the oil embargo crisis of
74 the commission was cranking out
emergency orders every day almost to
adjust energy rates there were National
emergencies in World War I and World War
II where the commission was very active
so I would just urge caution on the part
of the
legislature to be very judicious and how
they adjust this language in fact not to
put this bill forward because it's over
Brad language that would really hurt our
operations
thank
you thank you now I know you wanted to
speak only to the language of the bill
as
introduced but I have to ask
you if you could interpret the language
suggested by the consumer ad
Advocate that at the end of
line4 we add the phrase except for the
adoption of commission rules which
requires a majority of the
commission would you be willing to
comment on that or would you prefer
to defer a comment until you've had a
chance to talk to the Commissioners what
would be your your
pleasure my initial take on it I would
prefer to defer in terms of a formal
answer but I would suspect that chairman
goldner would respond saying uh I am the
administrative head of the agency and
this is an administrative task by
analogy chairman goldner wears the Hat
as the presiding officer and the
ultimate capital A administrator of the
site evaluation committee and so he has
the capability to do engage in
administrative reviews on his own there
uh of course it has to be subject to the
review of the full sight of evaluation
committee and furthermore the commission
rules have to be reviewed not only by
Jael car but substantively speaking they
are reviewed by the colleagues within
the Commission in an informal
consultative process so it's an
administrative task when the chairman
runs the rules hearing it's often as a
courtesy because a favorite time to do
rule I can say this having about 15
years of experience in the Commission in
terms of the beginning of my tenure um
the the the summertime is not a bad time
to have rules put forward for adoption
because uh there's a little bit of a
slackening in the work schedule and for
instance chairman goldner can run a
rules hearing when say one of the other
Commissioners is traveling abroad to
visit his family or uh driving on a
family vacation for a couple weeks it's
it's an amenity it's an administrative
amenity and I I don't personally see any
harm from that but I think uh perhaps
chairman goldner could give a formal
response as well to the committee if
you're interested on
that yes if you would ask for that we'd
appreciate that yes sir further
questions representative McGee has one
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being with us again so my question um in
your testimony you mentioned that having
three Commissioners available all the
time is not really workable but I don't
think that there's anything here that
suggests that all three need to be
present for things to for work to be
happening as was explained by the
consumer Advocate it it appears that
adjudicative decisions and rules um
being decided upon um that's what the
bill is related to is those those two um
aspects of commission business and so my
question is in the 15 years that you've
been involved how often has one
commissioner um decided on the rules by
themselves
is that something that's only recent or
uh has it was it always that way is it
is it unusual to have one commissioner
decide on the rules well
respectfully I think there's been a
little bit of backpedaling during the
course of the hearing regarding the
scope of the words presented here
because when you actually read the words
and you interpret them legally they say
that any order or any hearing must be
held by three Commissioners because of
the issuance of the strike through in
part two of this bill this is the bill
as it is
so leaving that
aside I would say
that whatever happened in 21 was done by
the legislature for good and valid
reasons but the structure of the bill as
it's presented here would result in the
inability of the commission to ever
issue an order or have any hearing
unless there were three Commissioners on
the roster whether through the
introduction of a special commissioner
or through the uh appointment of a full
roster of three Commissioners because of
the strike through the striketh through
is a very important deal and I'm very
rarely so blunt about things but I have
to make that
clear representative Harrington yeah
thank you I'm I'm I'm a little confused
now because you keep referring to saying
that it would require three
Commissioners to do anything but what
I'm reading this to say is that a
majority of the commissions shall
constitute a quorum and this chapter
majority leads at least 2third of the
commission regardless of any vacancies
so they would would require two why do
you keep saying three I'm a little
confused well because the legislature if
this enactment were to be passed would
be accepting the striketh through of the
language that refers to to issue orders
and any hearing may be held or conducted
by two Commissioners so if you're
removing that Authority as part of this
language in the context of saying that a
majority Quorum is at least 2third of
the commission the Supreme Court would
interpret that to mean that
aha you number one the legislature has
taken away your capability to have any
hearing or order issue with two
Commissioners and so ver therefore the
only logical explanation is that a
quorum is a quorum of three
Commissioners with two Commissioners in
agreement
or okay a
followup yes so I get this clear then if
if we would to write it
as the majority of the commission shall
constitute a quorum to issue orders and
any hearing may be held or conducted by
two Commissioners period get rid of or
by a single
commissioner that would then get clear
then that two Commissioners could issue
an order and two Commissioners could
have a
hearing if we get rid of that word or by
a single commissioner and left the other
words
in so are you proposing to uh move away
from I I think you had earlier in the
hearing Mr representative been
supporting the idea of having a single
commissioner available if there is no
objection under
36317 what I'm trying to do is is just
get this the meaning of this straight
because you seem to be interpreting as
written saying that if you review this
as a whole and you're the lawyer I'm not
so I'm going to think assume you know
more about this than I do that it could
be interpreted to say that as this uh
bill is proposed it would require three
Commissioners and what I'm saying is if
we got rid of if we left it in and just
got rid of the statement or by a single
commissioner would you then agree that a
two Commissioners could have a hearing
and could issue an order I'd have to see
the final language on that but that's a
definite improvement from completely
striking through the authority of the
commission to have a hearing with two
Commissioners oh okay thank you
further
questions representative McGee sorry I
do have one more question and that is
since what we've heard here is that the
I believe the intent of the bill is
to affect having a quorum available for
adjudicative decision- making and Ru
making so that is not explicitly called
out in this language and I think that
may be where the lack of
clarity seems to give rise to your
concerns that if it's written this way
then other things that the commission is
attempting to do might be also held to
that standard but I think the intent of
the language and the intent um of the
Prime sponsor was to get at the fact
that the decision- making and the rule
making coming out of the commission
should be conducted by a quorum of the
commission rather than by you know less
less than a
quorum so I wonder if the language meets
that as is uh as is unfortunately not uh
there are discussions about adjustments
but you know I would want uh the
commission to have the chance to respond
to those but it it it's statutory
construction is is kind of at the heart
of the matter and I've I've studied
administrative law at length as well and
when there's a statutory amb uity it
they default to the legislative intent
and sometimes you can get all the way to
the Finish Line with legislative intent
but when in doubt they'll say well the
legislature took a big red pencil and
did not want the commission and
adjudicative actions mean our orders are
hearings that's the meat and potatoes of
what we do so that's a lot of what we do
and so it's understood that there ought
to be and our tradition has been that we
always have two Commissioners present
for these adjudicative proceedings one
way or the other and so uh it's
important to recognize that the Supreme
Court can be ruthless in its uh
application of the literal words of the
statute that's what I would caution
against follow up um
so it when I my first question to you
was about whether or not there had ever
been one individual commissioner
responsible for rulle making do they is
that how it's been done traditionally I
don't think I ever really got an answer
on that
um is it common place or is it unusual
well I from what we heard today there
was a change in 21 where the chairman
could preside or the chair woman could
preside so in in the past it was it in
the past it was done by a quorum of the
Commissioners in the sense of there were
two or three Commissioners on the bench
ruling on these adoptions so that's how
it was before 2021 yeah and I think
that's what we're trying to clarify here
is that I don't think anybody realize we
changed it when that when the doe was
created that's fair okay further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you for being here to testify and with
that I'm going to close than the public
hearing on House Bill 16 9
FN we'll be starting an executive
session in a few minutes but before we
do that I want to ask representative PL
to read some results from blue sheets
and before I ask him to do that I'm
going to read some results
from the online remote
testimony portal that we have on the
House website
so
for House Bill
166 there were four people in support
and one person opposed the
bill for House Bill 306 there were 111
supporting and five
opposing and for House
Bill 169 there were two supporting and
two
opposing and for house Bill 526 there
were 24 supposing uh supporting and
seven
opposing and now representative P if you
could share with us the uh Mr chair you
missed one house bill
95 the reason I missed it is because I
don't have any data on that
one nobody um shared that with me oh I
take it back
there was one person in support and one
person
opposed now representative plog if you
could read the blue
sheet results for us thank you chair for
the house bill
306 there is two in favor one opposed
House Bill 166 one in favor none
opposed House Bill
95 none favor one opposed House Bill
526 five in favor two
opposed House Bill
169 two in favor none
opposed okay thank
you since we have a few minutes before
we begin our exact sessions this
afternoon I will uh let the committee
know that we will be meeting on Monday
and Tuesday of next
week I will post the
schedule
tomorrow of the bills that we'll be
hearing and that will appear in your
calendar on
um Thursday or Friday whenever the next
calendar is
published we very likely we'll do five
bills on Monday and maybe five bills on
Tuesday and there may be a executive
session in there as
well so you can use that for planning
purposes representative
parshall thank you thus clarify we're
still starting at 10
o'clock on Monday we'll start at 9
o' and previously we were starting on
Tuesday at 10 o'clock because there was
another meeting scheduled in this room
at nine o'clock but that meeting was
recently moved to a different room so we
can now start at 9:00 on Tuesday as well
so from here on
in pencil in that we'll be starting all
our meetings at 9
o' representative McGee do we have uh
chairs and vice chairs and ranking and
Deputy ranking meetings scheduled 9:00
am. on Tuesdays because yes
okay okay I'm not not sure about ranking
members but I know about shares and vice
shares um any other
comments
okay you have uh three minutes if you
need to uh stretch your
legs
e
e e
okay please take your seats everyone
I now open an executive session on House
Bill 10
6 establishing a commission to determine
the monetary costs of climate damage to
the state of New Hampshire and the best
means of recouping such costs and I
recognize Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chair on the motion uh for HB 106 uh I
make a motion to
itl chair recognizes representative
bney I second that motion moved in
second that
we adopt the motion of itl on House Bill
106 um discussion representative Vice
chair Thomas thank you Mr chair uh we
heard a lot of U testimony back and
forth u a lot of good testimony
indicating that you know weather is
changing we have a ups and downs but one
of the things that struck me the most
and that concerned me the most was that
uh there were predictions uh being put
forth as the basis for this bill and I'm
not quite sure that um it would be uh
prudent to um hold the commission based
on predictions especially since uh there
were a lot of pros and cons uh given
forth during the testimony as to actual
causes or what effects studies would
even have and one of the and one of the
things that were was mentioned was um
damages uh could they be attributed to
things done within the state would they
come over come in from overstate could
there be serious liabilities and uh you
know lawsuits presented if if uh if uh
companies complain that uh it wasn't
them but it was someone from Vermont
that uh that that did the duty the duty
deed so uh based on those things there I
think uh for lack of any hardcore um
absolutes it's it's in the best interest
to just itail this
bill further discussion representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um I I
don't believe that that constant Road
wash outs due to flooding um coastal
flooding impact to tourists with regard
to Winter Sports specifically skiing and
enjoying our lakes and the
uh proliferation of cyanobacteria in our
Lakes because of warm water is are are
those are not predictions those are um
actual impacts that we are seeing in our
state as a
result of of climate change and I think
that this uh commission is long time
overdue we're we're far behind all of
the other states in New England and and
if we don't get IR act together our
economy is going to suffer as a result
of
it additional
discussion representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair
um I just think it's uh it's a shame
that a serious issue has become a
political circus yet again and uh
because I I know it's ironic that if I
approached every single person on this
committee individually and I said
there's a longterm term intractable
problem that needs a whole of government
approach and we need to wrap our our
hands our heads around it and get our
hands on it so we can take care of it to
take care of our constituents every
single person on this committee would be
in favor of doing so but for some reason
when we talk about the climate it
becomes a toxic environment and we can't
drop the partisan baggage that has
plagued us for decades now around this
issue I I I say for some reason I know
the reason uh and it was mentioned by
somebody who was testifying at our
public hearing on Monday the young woman
from Bowden College when she talked
about the fossil fuel industry and their
propaganda campaign that's gone on for
decades uh to misinform and and divert
the public from understanding the the
causes of this issue and I know that the
people on this committee understand that
issue and and recognize it because no
nobody here is is is that misinformed
and the fact the fact of the matter is
we have part bipartisan bills in front
of us this session that mentioned
climate CL change and uh so that we know
that it's an issue that Republicans and
Democrats alike are aware of the problem
is that they they come at the problem
from from you know a little property tax
abatement over here a little Federal
grant money over there this requires a
uh to use a term of art that was favored
by our former colleague The Honorable
Becca McWilliams she she called it a
bucket this is an issue that needs its
own bucket and that's what this bill is
intended to do it creates a commission
where we can hear experts uh to try to
determine in a fiscally responsible
manner what are the financial damages
that we are looking at in the next few
years in our state in order to protect
our constituents and our communities
from the damages that we know are coming
and the preponderance of scientific
evidence has left us no doubt that that
is something that we will be facing and
to to to question that is just to it's
it's worse than will for ignorance it's
it's uh it's negligence and it's
dereliction of our duty this Commission
is basically taking a walk to the top of
the hill to see if the Indians are
coming and as far as I know in the
movies that I'm aware of people don't
say we're not going to walk to the top
of hill because we don't care if the
Indians are coming we do
care and so that's not what I signed up
for I signed up to take care of my
constituents to try to make this state a
better place for our children so I'll
leave it at that Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chair um I can app appreciate the
memb opposing point of belief I take
some umbrage as to the inference that uh
an opposite point of view has no merit
we heard uh testimony from Two
wellestablished and credible testifiers
that presented an opposite point of view
and because of that um despite our
differences of where we think things are
coming from respectfully thinking
there's enough uncertainty to not
subject the state to um unknown costs
when we don't know where those costs are
actually coming from or who's causing
them or what would be causing them and
also subjecting the potential of
liabilities in the state when we cannot
figure out if there were any such
damages where did they come from from
other states or other countries and who
would we blame them and if we try to
assess uh blame to one company how would
they prove or how would they wouldn't
prove that it didn't come from outside
the area leads to a whole bunch of
potential litigations so that's what we
believe and I think both points of view
have their their uh corners of um of of
support and I think the overall result
is just the overall uncertainty of just
what's happening here so respectfully um
uh we we need to be cautious in uh
moving forward that's why we should it
it this
bill repres representative Corman has a
point to make thank you actually I have
several so yeah I I I'm amazed here it
is it's 2025 and we're still debating
about climate change and some of the
things that we heard last week climate
change isn't real or if it's happening
human activity has nothing to do with it
or if humans are putting carbon into the
atmosphere that's not what's causing
temperatures to rise or if temperatures
are rising that's not what's causing
extreme weather events or in fact
there's no increase in EXT weather
events um I would just ask you know why
don't you guys like pick one and stick
with it
um you know we we heard earlier today
when you fail to plan you're planning to
fail and what this commission is trying
to do is plan for the effects of climate
change we are seeing it all around us I
actually uh was in touch with Jessica um
uh I forgot her last name here Jessica
from uh ski New Hampshire and she gave
me all sorts of information about how
it's affecting the ski industry what
they're finding and it's not just a
matter of uh fewer days it's a matter of
it's hard for them to even do snow
making because of droughts and because
of uh temperatures that don't promote
snow making so you know we're hearing it
in the recreational industry one other
point I'd like to make is um there there
was some some discussion about uh
the extreme weather events that have
happened how many were caused by climate
change and you can't draw a direct line
between an extreme weather event and a
particular facet of climate change
climate change creates conditions that
promote extreme weather events you can't
ask this question any more than you
could say to somebody who smokes
cigarettes and has lung cancer which
cigarette gave you the lung cancer it
doesn't work that way it's that it's
promoting this possibility it makes it
more likely that you have extreme
weather events it's not like this
weather event was caused by this aspect
of climate so you know I just feel like
we need to be understanding of climate
change and believe that it's happening
regardless of the cause it's happening
and we need to be able to adapt to it
and that's what this commission would be
trying to
do representative Summers thank you Mr
chairman
um so I look at this as a and and
forgive me for saying so but a
difference of being in science
technology energy and being that uh I I
see a difference between science and
religion and where I look at the science
I think of the different main difference
I view is the scientific method and
looking at the scientific method granted
after test hypothesis which we all would
do next would be draw conclusions of
what actually happened so we look at the
case in point look at the scientific
fact of the last ice age some folks
would say that right now we're at the um
according to written um L literature
that we're coming near the end of a the
last ice age some would say the last ice
age was caused by The Irregular oval of
the earth that's going around the Sun
and also there's a wobble of the axis of
the earth now I'm not saying this is
causing the the climate change rapid
temperature rate at this moment but what
I'm saying is to draw conclusions to be
able to end the scientific fact it's
it's to a point of where it's not
where're we're looking to impose damages
on something that is not proven
scientific fact it is
scientific not only maybe hypothesis
maybe Beyond hypothesis to drawing
conclusions but it's not fact at this
time as of scientific law thank
you representative
Swanson thank you Mr
chair I've seen the
expression I don't know what the future
holds but I know who holds the
future and I see a lot of assertions or
I'm hearing a lot of assertions that you
can't prove it's happening therefore it
isn't the future you know since I don't
think anybody's in this room and nobody
testify today who knows the
future and what we do as humans is we
take a look at things that have happened
we develop models and project into the
future and using that information and as
time passes if things start to happen
that conform to those models you have a
chance or good probability that your
models are accurate and with a large
preponderance of scientists who are
saying that there should be concern
then maybe instead of saying well you
can't prove it therefore we should
reject it and we won't do anything
doesn't feel like The Prudent thing to
do I think insurance companies are
probably leaders and doing probability
and putting dollar figures on it and
analyzing risk and that's what we're
talking about is taking a look at
analyzing risk of certain things
happening based upon other things that
have happened
and help people prepare for those
possible outcomes thank you for your
time additional comment representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman um I want to
bring it back to I to the people I
represent basically um when you drive
into my town there are signs from the
south and signs from the East that say
welcome to Hollis a farming
Community um I have very good
relationships with the farmers in my
town there are many farmers in my town
uh and they've been long established we
have a family in town at Brookdale Fruit
Farm who are on their eighth generation
in
Hollis um and I've talked to these folks
about the changes that they've been
seeing in their how they've had to
modify their farming practices there
isn't any question among these long
standing New Hampshire residents that
climate change is happening and it is
affecting their businesses is the crop
losses that we had last year um required
Federal funding and so maybe we didn't
feel the hit of that as significantly as
we might have if there wasn't Federal
funding um dedicated to the awareness
that communities are continuing to
suffer economic damage as a result of
warming temperatures
affecting um everything from uh the
growing season
to uh you know I mean no one really
cares if you tap the maples at a
different time of year as long as you
can still get the maple syrup but there
are many many changes that are happening
in the state of New Hampshire um earlier
today in testimony uh it was mentioned
that UNH is doing a significant amount
of work around what the changes are in
New Hampshire we've had testimony in
this Committee in the past on this very
topic we can can choose to ignore it and
say not something we have to worry about
but we I think the facts are on our side
I actually used chat GPT to ask some
objective questions after our hearings
last week about fossil fuel consumption
about climate
damage and the various categories that
those damages fall into in terms of
economics and to kind of reiterate
represent this the prime sponsor um
representative kaplan's point it it
borders on negligence if we're not
looking at this and I I you know I'm I'm
actually pretty um measured in the
language that I use in this committee
but for us to say over and over that
there isn't even any benefit in US
looking into it so that we can figure
out what threats there are to our
economy and to the businesses in this
state like the farmers in my community
um and also to look at if there are any
potential ways to recover monies that
the state will suffer as a result of
these changes I mean who else's job is
it so that's where I stand on the bill
it's if not us who you know we're we're
the people who are responsible for
getting that information and figuring
out if there is any action that should
be taken on behalf of the folks who were
losing money because of the warming
conditions so that's all I have to say
representative
rolds thank you Mr
chairman I do not
purport to
be
smarter
than all of
the
collective
expertise and Analysis
of all the scientists in the National
Academy of
Sciences the American geophysical
Union the American Association for the
advancement of
science but I have
read the statements of each of those
organizations which of course are
available to any of us on their websites
and all of those organizations and
therefore all of the thousands of
scientists that they
represent have stated unequivocally that
climate change is real and human
activities are causing it at a very high
confidence
level when I introduced my myself to
this committee um last week two weeks
ago you know I stated that one of the
positions I had in my past was working
for a non National nonprofit
organization called the union of
concerned scientists and I was the
Northeast climate policy
coordinator for three plus years and in
that role was involved in publicizing a
study it was actually a sort of a meta
study
uh which is to say a combination
of large number of of different studies
into one synthesis report called the
Northeast climate impacts assessment
published in 2007 so almost 20 years ago
and the projected impacts of climate
change on the north east and we even did
individual reports on each individual
state describing the projected impacts
of climate
change almost 20 years ago and they and
those reports discussed things like
impacts on
Fisheries from warming Coastal Waters
impacts on the ski and tourism more
broadly the tourism industry you know
snowmobiling is a huge tourism business
in the state of New
Hampshire um impacts on agriculture imps
on
forestry and all of those impacts are
being felt today I don't think anybody
can honestly say that the increasingly
erratic weather and warming temperatures
that we' see are not
affecting the uh economics of this state
the businesses of this state and the
residents of this state um the ice in
and Ice outdates
shrinking uh and
so this bill is not is a bill that
would put this state on a path
to
document those
impacts put a price tag on those impacts
and position New
Hampshire
to PO eventually seek to recover some of
those
costs not from other residents of New
Hampshire but from the global fossil
fuel
industry that has engaged as we heard
testimony and as we've all
seen documented uh you know conducted a
40-year plus campaign of
disinformation that fossil fuels you
know were not any cause of climate
climate change there's a very strong
parallel
to the tobacco settlement to the damages
caused
by smoking and the eventual multi-state
lawsuit that resulted in a multi-million
dollar settlement with the tobacco
industry which New Hampshire partook in
and New Hampshire received benefits from
so this bill is about as representative
McGee said positioning New Hampshire to
be
prepared to protect its citizens from
something that we can all see is
happening thank you representative I
think uh we've all had a chance to State
our positions
here I'm going to close this uh
hearing this executive session after
representative Harrington gives us his P
thank I'll make this very quick there's
been lots of talk about uh brainwashing
and false information being put out by
the evil oil companies and all that just
look up uh Earth Day predictions alore
predictions we were going to have no GL
no ice on the North Pole uh I think that
was going to happen like five or six
years ago the day of no return was going
to be sometime around 2015 if we didn't
reduce uh greenhouse gas emission it was
the beginning of the end and since then
we have not reduced them we've increased
them drastically because of countries
like India and China so I've got to take
it a little lightly when you cut
everyone starts talking about all these
all these evil people putting out all
these evil thoughts look to your own
side because they've been putting out
junk for a long time prediction after
prediction that just doesn't come true
and they ignore it and just move on and
make another one
so all right I think we need to move on
so uh
I want to just close here by saying that
I don't know anybody who doesn't
recognize that we are experiencing mild
and minor changes to the
climate we don't know exactly what
causes those
changes we also don't know what the
long-term impact of those changes is
going to be a lot of people want to make
predictions a lot of people do make
predictions and they're not very often
correct the bottom line here is that
this is a worldwide
phenomenon and there is very little that
New Hampshire can do about it one way or
the other whether we prepare for it or
we don't that's going to be a
daytoday process of
adaptation and I don't think we need to
waste resources studying what those
predictions will incor correctly
produce so with that I would like to ask
priv Clerk of the priv could I have a
final word because I'd like to
no the clerk of the committee I would
ask him to call the role on the question
of itl on House Bill
106 Vice chairman Thomas
yes representative n yes representative
Harrington yes representative Ry yes yes
representative Bernardi clerk yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative sneller schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan no
representative Wendy Thomas no
representative Cor
no Representative rolds no
representative l relle no represent
Swanson no chairman Vose yes 10 to
eight by a vote of 10 to8 the Comm
committee adopts the motion of itl on
House Bill 106 representative Thomas
will write the majority report will
there will there be a Minority Report
Tony kapan Tony will write The Minority
Report please have that report to me by
uh 7 am tomorrow morning as I need to
get it to the clerk before noon
tomorrow and with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill
106 and now I'm going to open a
306 establishing a commission to study
the short and long-term impacts of
pending National and Regional carbon
pricing mechanisms on New Hampshire
citizens businesses institutions and
environment and I recognize
representative nder for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I move
itl chair recognizes representative
Bernardi second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of itl
for House Bill
306 represent ative nter is recognized
thank you Mr
chairman we all know that the purpose of
a commission is to recommend future
legislation that future legislation
would be carbon
pricing the chairman chairman Bose Vice
chairman Thomas and I have been on the
science technology and energy committee
since
2015 in 2019 you may recall we had an
all day hearing on carbon pricing that
was House Bill 735
I have it right
here here's the testimony from that
day put in a file folder with the uh
Eiffel Tower as a reminder that they did
this in France and the people revolted
they took to the streets because it was
so expensive the fiscal note I have here
from that
bill went up to $795 million that was
the price tag we never had the debate on
the house floor because the chairman at
the time Bob bakis tabled the
bill in the hearing
today we heard testimony that the town
of miramac wants
this well I was there at that that town
meeting and let me tell you something
about the town elections in miramac
hardly anybody goes to them hardly it's
it's it's pathetic voter apathy prevails
unless there's a big ticket item like an
enormously expensive SAU
building in a fall election that's when
the people come out to vote
town it's it's really not there so if
climate change and carbon pricing were
the number one issue in
marac then the sponsored this bill would
have top the ticket and I wouldn't be
here there's no
National or Regional carbon pricing
mechanisms currently before Congress and
none are likely in the next four years
House Bill 306 is a duplicate of last
year's House Bill
372 we ited that bill last year and I
believe we should do it again this year
thank
you further discussion representative
Wendy Thomas oh yes thank you Mr chair
uh first of all it is uh I'm also from
the town of marac it is very interesting
to hear Representatives say that we have
voter apathy and that our town elections
are pathetic I will make sure that uh
that message gets back uh Mr chair you
asked um when I was testifying if this
was the same bill that was passed as
last term and I answered that yes it was
um and that is because people are
begging us to pay attention they are
begging us to recognize that carbon
pricing is seen as something that is
that is coming down the road and it is
going to impact our economy in New
Hampshire I know that every time we call
it carbon pricing you guys call it
carbon tax because you know that tax is
the evil word um this is not a tax on
energy this is a tax on
polluters um it's and and the the intent
is for climate protections we also know
that in the case of of Canada people are
getting rebates from these from these uh
from the carbon uh pricing it is just
this this conversation piggybacks on the
one that we just had we are closing our
eyes to something that is out there
something that is going to happen
something that is going to greatly
affect our economy and we need to to
take a look at it thank
you further
discussion representative Summers thank
you Mr chairman
um while while I do hear the argument
that uh folks are begging for the uh for
this bill to come back for the uh for
carbon uh carbon pricing increase I've
also probably had just as many if not
more constituents ask and beg for lower
fuel prices lower electrical rates and
lower uh um energy alog together so this
is why I'd be it the spill as well
Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr chair um
it's interesting we've been talking
about carbon pricing uh almost since
I've been on this committee I've spoken
in the well about it a couple of times
and the one overriding factor that I
keep reading about is Europe is years
ahead of us in carbon pricing they've
been doing it for a long time as uh my
good friend representative noted uh
interestingly enough
the uh emissions haven't gone down
enough to cause any appreciable
difference in the rate of increase in
the temperature of the the atmosphere
and uh that begs me to wonder just how
effective carbon pricing is now I have
read uh several uh reports from
institutions uh many economists agree
that car carbon pricing could work in
reducing the amount of carbon in the air
if that's what you wanted to do if it
was effective but almost all of them say
that it would be at such a high cost it
would be politically and legislatively
impossible to pass the costs the
economic costs to uh fuels would be so
high as to people would Rebel as we're
seeing around the world they're starting
to do now and any costs that are lower
than that threshold really wouldn't have
that much of an effect so I stand by
those stats saying that carbon pricing
is a great way to raise money for for
countries and that they have done and
what they can do with that money they
like to have a lot of money but as far
as affecting our environment uh the jury
is still out on that but we do know that
if you follow the money it's a lot of
people that are in favor of that so uh I
think we're doing the right thing here
with with itl
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman I've s I've heard a couple of
uh comments here that don't really
relate to the bill or the intent of the
bill um I I think the one thing everyone
on the committee agrees with is that we
would like to be able to lower people's
costs for energy and figure out bills
that we can pass that actually help us
to support people keeping their costs
low I I think this bill intends to have
us become more educated I'll use
representative ammon's language and say
it's a sunlight bill right it's it's a
bill that would answer questions that
people have around carbon pricing that
is coming all around us and what effect
that might have on us we don't know
what's going to raise our costs or lower
our costs if we don't bother to look at
it and this Bill is saying this stuff is
all around us everybody in North America
is pricing their carbon products and
we're not uh and most of our major
trading partners are are pricing carbon
into their products and they're also
going to start charging people who are
not participating in that carbon Market
okay so it's an entire Market we are not
participating this bill doesn't say we
need to participate it says we need to
to know what's going on and we need to
understand how it will impact people's
costs here and if we don't have that
information can't make good decisions
can't make future future legislation but
if you kill the bill here in its infancy
before we've actually had a chance to
study it then we have no more
information and it's just one more year
of DeLay So this is not the same as 7:35
I was here for
735 that bill was talking about adopting
carbon pricing and everyone thought that
it was untenable for New Hampshire to
try and make a move like that on its own
it wasn't wasn't really the right
vehicle and it it didn't make sense and
so yeah it was killed on our committee
by
democrats so that's not what we're
trying to do here what we're trying to
do is say we should study this because
it's coming whether we're looking you
know walking to the mountain top to look
and see if the Indians are coming or
not representative Kaplan
thank you Mr chair yeah I just want to
piggyback on representative McGee's
comments they're so they're so apt um
and I just also want to commend my
Republican colleagues for their concern
on the environment and the possible
impacts of of a carbon pricing mechanism
um I would just say that if we do want
to lower carbon emissions and have a
positive impact on our environment this
that we should at least look at what
other countries are doing because that's
why they enacted a car carbon pricing
mechanism so if it's not working there
uh as representative Thomas suggested we
ought to know about it something the
commission uh of of this sort would find
out so again this is just uh you know
sunlight as uh represent McGee said it's
information it's Gathering and it's uh
it's something we ought to do if we
cared about uh planning for the
future the voters of New Hampshire have
been telling the governors and the
representatives that they
elect since the
1950s that they do not want a sales tax
an income tax or any other kind of
broad-based
tax National surveys consistently have
shown over the last 25 years that 60% of
Voters oppose a carbon
tax this is not something our
constituents want us to
do therefore I recommend that we don't
do
this is there any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl for House Bill
306 Vice shair
Thomas yes representative nder yes
representative Harrington yes
representative rney yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative scheller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan no
representative Thomas emphatically no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no no representative La relle no
representative
Swanson absolutely no chairman
Vose yes
10 before I announce
the result of the election I'd point out
that a yes or a no is sufficient for
your vote we don't need any other words
or adjectives appended to your vote so
by a vote of 8 the committee adopts the
position of itl for House Bill
306 representative n will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report yes there will representative
Wendy Thomas will write
the uh major Minority Report and I need
that by 7 a.m. tomorrow please it is in
your inbox thank
you with that we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 306 6 and um open
the public hearing executive session
rather on 306 and open an executive
session on House Bill 526 FN
establishing a CH climate change and
damage division in the Department of
Environmental Services and I recognize
representative nder for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I move itl I recognize
representative schneller second moved
and seconded that we adopt the motion of
itl on House Bill 526 FM representative
nter thank you Mr chairman very simple
it it creates a new department that we
cannot afford so I know the opposition
will disagree with that but um that's my
statement and simple as
that representative schneller uh this
assumes climate damage that has not yet
been seen thank you
further
comment representative Wendy Thomas
thank you I would like to uh refute that
previous uh statement by saying this is
something we can't afford not to do um
as far as a climate damage that we
haven't seen that um that I I don't
understand that statement because we
have seen um with increased flooding in
the summer we have seen roads wash out
that are costing our state millions of
dollars as the temperature gets up
higher in the summer as we all know
those of us that have taken science you
know that warm air contains more
moisture which is why we're seeing so
much flooding in the summer we're seeing
uh decreased snow in the winter uh
that's affecting our uh tourist industry
the snow um the skiing industry is is
hurting um again we we seem to be on a
roll with these um the tourists that
come up for our our Lakes our the W the
standing bodies of water are getting
warmer we're getting
cyanobacteria which are toxic blooms
that impede enjoying the
Lakes um to say that you're not we're
also seeing droughts there's no doubt in
my mind that we're going to be seeing uh
wildfires uh very soon um to say that
climate change hasn't caused any damage
is to be irresponsible thank you
any further discussion representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman yeah I I
have to agree with uh representative
Wendy Thomas I mean we're we're seeing
all sorts of damage whether it's uh in
in my area of the Upper Valley where
we've been having significant flooding
events uh what's happened on the Sea
Coast we haven't had the wildfires here
yet but we sure get the smoke from them
especially from our neighbors to the
north um I mentioned the ski industry
before uh so Jessica Keeler from ski New
Hampshire says we deal with factors that
include extreme weather such as droughts
that impact our ability to make snow
like some ski areas experien this year
or flooding which has wreak havoc either
on ski area infrastructure or the roads
and bridges that lead to the ski areas
or heavy rains when it should be snowing
or a season in which we do open late
because of unseasonable temperatures or
close earlier than expected for the same
reason in the spring particularly when
it gets warm earlier in the spring it
becomes harder to convince people to ski
because they're already thinking about
other outdoor activities so we're seeing
the effect on our tourism industry we're
seeing the effect just in general we're
seeing it in the air it it it's
happening and uh again to deny it we're
just putting our heads in the sand and
you know I don't think we're all
ostes I agree it's happening
I disagree that it's climate I think
it's weather that's what's happening
representative
Bernardi I agree with you Mr chairman
the worst and the hottest days in the
United States on record were in the
1930s the Dust Bowl not
now the greatest floods in New Hampshire
occurred in the
1950s not
now the
worst Coastal storm
that we've had
recently
1978 so we are not seeing a continual
trend of
catastrophism year after year after year
I reject that
premise representative
Summers not to dispute or argue this
debate this debate will continue to go
on however if we really wanted to make a
change on on climate change and we were
really serious about it and we really
wanted to go to effect that where
something would actually take effect now
I know how the opposite party at least
nationally is against tariffs however
imposing a 100% tariff on China and
India for climate change and imposing
that they do something about their 85%
the pollution that is in the world then
we would have according to what I last
testified under the scientific method
then we would have proof If the climate
actually did go down or get better
because of their drop of the 85% the
problem then maybe this would prove not
only that it is an actual issue but
you'd be actually attacking the actual
cause of the bulk of the problem
cleaning up the little State of New
Hampshire or even like I said going
taking us all the way down to zero will
have almost no effect compared to the
85% of India and China so we actually
have to tax the actual problem cause
them some pain over it if you really
want to make a ground effect on climate
change and you really think it's a
severe issue and more than just in a
religion but scientific fact you would
actually attack China and India
nationally instead of trying to do it at
a one little state in the New England
area representative
Kaplan yeah I got two words for you
carbon pricing mechanisms three that's
three words but I'm surprised you voted
against it that's exactly what you're
talking about this taxing other
countries for their carbon content
that's what we were talking about in the
last bill which you just voted against
um Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chairman um I'd like to pay you back on
a major Point made by representative
Bernardi something that I think people
now um may not have realized
but consider now with all of the
informational structure we have out
there social media and the amount of
population and buildings and and
infrastructure that we have now as
opposed to say back in the 1930s uh uh
1950s the weather the the extreme
weathers have happened all throughout
our history but the effects the economic
effects are in people people's minds
much more vast now because of the E we
have more population we have more
buildings the cost factors are more
because of inflation and so forth and so
on so it seems to people here now that
all of a sudden we're having this
climate change or this weather change in
my opinion I believe that the sure the
effects nowadays are more stringent
because we have more out there that's
being affected by these Chang but the
actual weather pattern seems to be
pretty consistent over the last several
hundred years so I would caution people
as to making the leaping Assumption of
the cause and effects and instead I
think people should just go out there
and say look every so often we're going
to have a bad winter a bad summer a bad
flood whatever maybe take it upon
themselves to figure out how things
should should be uh uh prepared for that
instead of subjecting economies to a lot
of expenses on things the weather that
we really have no real control over uh
on a worldwide
basis so you're saying we have to avoid
falling victim to
presentism evaluating everything that
happens according to what we see in the
present when in fact the past may
contain or may have seen events that
were much more traumatic than what we're
seeing
today TS Elliot
said human beings have a limited
capability for
reality and I think a lot of
our disagreement about climate
change is
because we all
struggle with figuring out what's real
what is
reality I don't know that we're going to
be able to figure it out here in this
executive
session but I think we should avoid
doing anything
that puts our constituents at the
risk of energy
poverty puts our constituents at the
risk of
being made poor
by bad decisions that we make In the
Heat of the
Moment so I'd like to ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of
itl for House Bill 526
FN Vice chair Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative brny yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative
Matson yes representative scheller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative
Kaplan no representative Thomas no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no representative La relle no
repres restive Swanson no chairman Vose
yes
10 by a vote of 10 to8 the committee
adopts the resolution of itl for House
Bill 526
FN representative nter will write
the majority report will there be a
Minority
Report representative Wendy Thomas will
write The Minority Report it is in your
inbox
thank you very much Mr chairman before
we break yes um I had asked the um our
secretary to pull put together copies of
yeah and they stopped somewhere along
here they didn't keep coming so if we
could get those for how folks are going
to change their email
address so it has been asking us to do
that yeah they're
coming e